it was November 3rd 1991 and Blake
Newsome loved his job he had a passion
for organization an Undying Love of
American political history and was a
lifelong member of the Republican party
that's why he took great pride in his
position as a filing clerk at the Ronald
Reagan Presidential Library or at least
he did until his horrifying encounter
with
scp-1981 the worst day of Blake's life
began like any other he was taking
inventory of the archive's wide array of
betamax tapes and making sure that they
were all arranged carefully and
conformed with the filing system one by
one he checked footage of speeches and
addresses off of his list until he came
upon a strange tape that had no business
being there the tape looked to be
completely normal but it hadn't been
recorded on the archive inventory and
there was something else off about it a
single white sticker was on the front of
the tape with Ronald Reagan cut up while
talking squalled hastily with what was
probably a felt tip marker Blake was
shocked in a palm they hadn't even
spelled the president's name correctly
what poor Mr Newsome didn't know was
that he was about to see something so
disturbing that he'd look back on that
misspelling like it was a treasured
childhood memory
standard policy for tapes like this
would be to review and catalog or even
throw it out if necessary typically a
lowly filing clerk like Blake would need
to seek approval from his superiors but
curiosity got the better of him he
commandeered one of the library's
televisions and betamax cassette players
and started watching the footage for the
first minute or so nothing seemed out of
the ordinary
just the president standing at the
podium giving his iconic evil empire
speech to the National Association of
evangelicals at Sheraton Twin Towers
Hotel Orlando Florida on March 8 1983.
however the second the tape hit the one
minute and 10 seconds Mark something
unnatural began to occur President
Reagan's speech began to Veer off as the
topic of conversation shifted from the
importance of family values to the
Exquisite Taste of human flesh Blake was
taken aback surely he was hearing things
but the tape only got worse President
Reagan began to divulge the fact that he
enjoyed the taste of young flesh the
best particularly that of infants as
Reagan began to go into detail about how
exactly one should best cook an infant
if you want to seal in the flavor the
crowd erupted into modest Applause Blake
started to feel sick he'd remembered
watching this speech and President
Reagan had said nothing of the sore
things only got weirder as the
president's cheek suddenly opened up
into a long bleeding gash as though
someone had cut into his face with an
invisible knife has the speech continued
and Reagan's words became more
nonsensical and incoherent the injuries
got worse too his face developed
puncture wounds like he was being
stabbed skin in some areas rotted and
peeled off Reagan showed no awareness of
the horrifying injuries that seemed to
be occurring spontaneously on his body
this was a living nightmare the tape
came to a merciful end 22 minutes in
after President Reagan's throat appeared
to be slashed open and his insane speech
was reduced to quiet gurgles
it fizzled out into static shortly after
and Blake politely retired to the
bathroom to throw up was this some sick
prank or tampering or camera trickery
perhaps he didn't know but the tape was
disgusting and whoever was responsible
had to be punished Newsome contacted the
police hoping obscenity charges could be
pressed against the creator of the tape
once they were found the tape was taken
into evidence and a low-level police
investigation into the possible culprits
began while the police officers who
viewed the tape reported nightmares in
the weeks following the creator of the
tape was never found the investigation
truly came to an end when a superior
closed the case and the tape disappeared
from the evidence Locker this as you
probably could have guessed was the work
of a field agent from the SCP Foundation
anistex were then used to erase the
memories of everyone unlucky enough to
witness the tape including Blake Newsome
who could finally rest easy and return
to his filing work
the anomalous tape was now in
responsible hands it was given the
designation
scp-1981 and given the object class safe
due to its easily controlled and
self-contained nature proper research
and testing was now able to begin and
while nothing about the construction of
the tape suggested anything inherently
anomalous repeat viewings of the video
made it clear that this went far beyond
mere doctored footage of a presidential
speech every single time the tape is
played both the speech made and the
injuries received by President Reagan
change the few rules the tape seem to
always follow are that Reagan never
reacts to the injuries he's receiving it
always has the same beginning and total
run time and the speech is always
corrupted the speeches have been
described as mostly incoherent lacking
any sort of underlying thematic
structure and largely being composed of
nonsensical anecdotes and parables so
not that dissimilar from a regular
Reagan speech but the topics always turn
incredibly dark and have included
torture mutilation death cannibalism
ritual sacrifice genocide and more the
range of injuries shown on President
Reagan in the videos have included but
are by no means limited to impalement
mutilation and some tortures so gruesome
that the details have been redacted from
official files on several occasions the
details of President Reagan's speech
have also eerily predicted the Future
these include successfully predicting
the September 11th attacks in 2001 and
the outcome of the 2008 Russian
presidential election incidentally this
isn't even the only reagan-related SCP
to predict the future
no there's another entity in this
incredibly specific Niche
scp-095 a highly degraded copy of a
comic known as the atomic Adventures of
Ronnie raygun
the Title Character Bears a striking
resemblance to President Reagan despite
the fact that the comet is confirmed by
Foundation tests to have been written in
the early 1930s
the comic is set in the far-off future
world of the 1980s and follows a number
of Ronnie's exploits in three stories
the first titled Ronnie vs Space Admiral
Carter seems to perfectly describe the
events of the 1980 presidential election
the second space assassin mirrors the
attempted assassination of President
Reagan by John Hinckley Jr and the third
titled jungle Planet retells the
Iran-Contra controversies of 1986.
these Comics were produced under the
mysterious and apparently non-existing
company future funnies the foundation
hopes to track down the other comics
from this company whenever possible but
they've had no luck on that front for
now there's only
scp-095 during initial testing
Foundation staff watched the tape
frequently in case this strange
corrupted version of President Reagan
had any other valuable predictions for
the future
however during one of these screenings
one of the d-class observation Personnel
pointed and yelled at the screen in
horror upon further examination of
recorded footage researchers could see
exactly what had concerned The d-class
Observer so much
while in other viewings of the tape
President Reagan's press detail had
appeared totally normal and this one
something was clearly amiss standing
among the other dull suit-wearing
political AIDS was a tall figure dressed
in a midnight black cloak with a large
conical Hood obscuring his face the
figure didn't appear to move in the
footage it just stood there menacingly a
later survey indicated that this figure
would appear in roughly one in seven
viewings of the tape
this cloaked figure was designated
scp-1981-1 and he became part of the
reoccurring imagery in the nightmares
that often followed a viewing of
scp-1981. naturally despite containment
and preservation attempts the foundation
was aware that just like any normal tape
natural magnetic interference would
eventually degrade it Beyond use
attempts to copy the footage onto
another betamax tape failed to reproduce
the anomalous effects
that's why the foundation has
painstakingly recorded any video and
audio they could via standard commercial
camcorder in one particularly terrifying
playback
scp-1981-1 took the president's place at
the podium staring directly into the
camera the words I see you appeared over
a black screen shortly after staff
members were ordered never to make an
attempt at communicating with the figure
and instead contact a level 4 Superior
if such an event occurs during a
playback again
the frightening and unfortunate effects
of scp-1981 would come to their logical
conclusion under the watchful eye of Dr
James Kyle Robinson managing archivist
of inert safe class objects and
anomalous items at site 73. he was
contacted by special agent Arnold
Rodriguez and special agent Ethan Tate
members of the Secret Service with a
duty to protect President Reagan word
had gotten to Reagan that there was an
anomalous artifact in the possession of
the foundation that directly pertained
to him and he wanted to see it
Dr Robinson obtained files and
transcripts pertaining to scp-1981 and
handed them over to the agents but
refused to allow President Reagan to see
the tape directly without approval from
o5 command the Reagan and the Agents
were persistent eventually o5 command
ordered a private screening of the tape
for President Reagan at the Sanford
chemical processing plan a front
business owned and operated by the
foundation for amnesic production Dr
Robinson offered President Reagan the
use of amnestics after the session
completed but Reagan declined the
screening took place in conference room
B and the tape was replayed three times
it was on the third playback that things
took an interesting turn as the
mutilated Reagan on the screen began to
rant about drinking the blood of a child
from the skull of Vladimir Putin Reagan
began to silently mouth along the words
as though he remembered them he spoke
about beings known as the Destroyers and
potential apocalyptic events to come
after the screening Reagan once again
refused the offer of amnestics and
departed
it seemed as though all was well until a
violent break-in at the Sanford chemical
processing plant that left a night guard
dead
a large number of amnestics had been
stolen during the break-in and security
footage showed that agent Tate and
Rodriguez had been responsible the two
agents were tracked down and traced to
the residents of Ronald Reagan where the
foundation Came Upon a disturbing site
the agents had pillaged large quantities
of Class A and B amnestics and supplied
them to President Reagan who at some
point after observing scp-1981 had been
driven into a dangerous Madness the two
agents wanted to cure him before he
caused harm to himself or others but
their bungling had come with severe
consequences misapplying such a high
quantity of amnestics had essentially
destroyed Reagan's mind while the
foundation was able to stabilize his
condition his impaired memory and
cognitive function would leave him
unable to care for himself independently
in order to cover up for this Grievous
mistake a cover story was concocted
about Reagan falling victim to
Alzheimer's and facing severe cognitive
decline as a result
both agents tayden Rodriguez were fired
for their actions had their memories
wiped by the foundation and were
assigned new identities Dr Robinson for
his part in the disaster had to face a
foundation Ethics Committee disciplinary
hearing while scp-1981 continues to be
classified as safe due to its
unlikeliness to ever breach containment
when you consider the havoc and Rod on
the mind of its singular Target safe is
hardly the word that comes to mind it's
enough to make you wonder what other
tapes are lurking out there just waiting
to be found every time a bell rings an
angel gets its wings it's an iconic line
from It's a Wonderful Life and even if
you don't believe in angels it is a
pleasant image after all angels are the
embodiment of goodness and light so an
angel getting its wings has to be a good
thing right well as anyone who's ever
eaten one too many Christmas cookies can
tell you it's possible to have too much
of a good thing even something that
sounds like the embodiment of all things
good in theory can become deadly when
taken to the extreme that is where
scp-469 also known as the many winged
angel comes in the this angel-like
creature is anything but innocent and in
fact it has been responsible for
multiple deaths of SCP Foundation
Personnel during its captivity
scp-469 may be deadly but it is also
undeniably beautiful in a mysterious
ethereal way when first seen it appears
to be nothing more than a massive pile
of pristine white feathers like
something out of a pillow commercial the
pile measures 24 feet in diameter and
weighs at least two tons however like
many of the entities contained within
the walls of the foundation's countless
containment sites all is not as it seems
with 469. what looks at first glance to
be a pile of feathers is in fact a dense
curled mass of giant wings the wings
vary in size from the tiny wingspan of a
sparrow to the Staggering 3.6 meter
wingspan of the wandering Albatross the
one thing they have in common is their
plumage with each Wing being covered
with the same glossy white feathers the
foundation was able to perform a series
of x-rays on the mass of wings revealing
a skeletal structure beneath the
feathers like those of a bird the wings
bones are Hollow however they are
unnaturally soft and flexible allowing
for a range of motion that no known bird
possesses this accounts for the
curvature of the Wings and their ability
to coil tightly into each other the
X-ray also provided the first and only
recorded Glimpse at the creature hiding
underneath all the feathers at the
center of the layers upon layers of
wings is a humanoid creature curled into
a fetal position in defiance of the laws
of natural Anatomy every single wing
appears to be fused to this creature's
spine how would it be able to move under
the weight of these wings or even if it
could is as of yet unknown the First
Foundation Personnel lost to scp-469
were d-class personnel d-112 and d-624
who were sent into investigate the
nature of the creature and attempt to
contact the humanoid entity identified
on the x-rays one one two and six two
four entered the room equipped with
gloves and protective eye gear as
scientists watched the situation unfold
on a monitor on a video feed No One
expected much to come with the encounter
the working hypothesis was the layers of
feathers would simply be too thick to
get through without seriously damaging
the bones it would be a fairly
uneventful experiment or so they thought
112 approached
scp-469 first and attempted to depart a
section of its feathers with his hands
as 624 stood back and observed the
moment his fingertips touched the
feathers a rustling sound filled the
room the feathers began to quiver
shaking as if all waking up at once from
a deep Slumber suddenly in the blink of
an eye the hundreds and hundreds of
wings unfurled and pulled one one two
into their deaths he was swept into a
swirl of feathers and within seconds he
it disappeared from view completely
though 624 and the scientists watching
on their monitor could no longer see it
they could certainly hear him from the
moment the wings pulled him into the sea
of feathers 112 had begun to scream in
agony his screams persisted growing
louder and more desperate even as the
voice cracked and grew weak 624 stood
Frozen in place with fear and shock 624
was ordered to attempt to retrieve 112
from the feathers but made no move to do
so he simply stared at the feathers eyes
wide face pale has the pain shrieks of
his colleague bounced off the sterile
White Walls of the containment room a
guard called over the intercom
threatening to terminate 624 if he did
not attempt to remove 112 from
scp-469's grasp this warning seemed to
shock 6-4 back into action and he made a
run for the center feathers arms up to
protect his face again the sound of
rustling as the feathers began to Quake
the wings on referred once more and 624
did not even have a chance to turn back
before he was pulled in to meet the same
dismal fate as the other d-class his
screams of pain joined 112 as the
scientists watching over the monitor
could do nothing to help them as the two
men cried out in pain and horror from
within their winged prisons something
began to happen that the scientists had
never seen before the feathers started
to shake again faster than before and at
first the wings appeared to be unfolding
again upon second look though it was
clear they hadn't moved there were
simply more of them now as the men
continued to scream more feathers
appeared the wings stretching out and
elongating as new Wings sprouted as if
from nowhere
scp-469 appeared to be feeding on the
sound of their screams and using that
energy to expand it was only after
several long minutes when the screaming
finally stopped that the growth of the
Wings did too at this point the wings
shifted again expelling the bodies of
112 when 624 from within its folds
dropping them limply on the ground
though their deaths were unfortunate the
loss of 112 and 624 did reveal some new
information about
scp-469 first that it could grow and
apparently needed to feed on sounds in
order to do so second that it was deadly
to humans and most likely to other
living things as well autopsies of 112
and 62 Force corpses would later reveal
exactly what happened to them and how
scp-469 kills its prey the 469's
feathers may look as though they would
be soft to the touch each feather is
actually made up of sharp barbs that are
capable of piercing clothing and skin
these barbs release a neurotoxin into
the system that activates every pain
receptor in the body of the victim the
neurotoxin present in these feathers has
not been identified anywhere else in
nature but is somewhat similar in
structure and function to the
neurotoxins excreted by the cone snail
and in the bite of the blue
octopus in addition to the pain-inducing
neurotoxin the feathers also carry
several unidentified stimulant compounds
where the neurotoxin on its own would
induce enough pain for the affected
party to pass out almost immediately the
stimulants serve to keep the victim
conscious SCP Foundation scientists
posit that this is so that 469 can get
as much noise in this case in the form
of Screams out of its pain as possible
and Achieve maximum growth before the
captive creature dies or goes into shock
further experiments confirmed this
Theory and showed that scp-469 will
react similarly when exposed to any
living creature capable of making a
sound and experiencing pain not just
humans non-living matter though
including dead animals elicit no
response from 469 additional experiments
were then undertaken that involved
applying various different sounds in
order to test their effect on
scp-469's growth though it feeds on any
sounds produced in in its presence it
seems to respond most strongly to
musical sounds exhibiting a particularly
strong response to classical music no
sound elicits a stronger reaction from
this creature however than the sound of
ringing Bells it is rumored that when a
bell was wrong in the presence of 469
the humanoid at the center of the
feathers is said to have moved for the
first time on record apparently whatever
is at the center appeared to wake up and
unfurl its wings revealing itself but
unfortunately all security footage of
this incident has been White and the
data has been expunged from the record
leaving the creature's true form a
mystery you may be remembering that four
members of foundation Personnel on
record were lost to scp-469 and that
only two have been mentioned so far the
second pair of casualties resulted when
the foundation attempted to terminate
scp-469 believing that there was no more
scientific benefit to keeping it alive
or at least that the possible benefits
did not outweigh the red desks it was
ordered that scp-469 be terminated by
any means necessary two skilled
Personnel Dr Jones and Dr Smith were
sent into the containment facility in
Hazmat gear armed with several sharp
instruments they were to attempt to use
these to cut through the forest of
feathers and soft bones until they could
reach the humanoid at the center it was
presumed that once they did and the
creature no longer had the protection of
its poisonous feathers that it would be
relatively easy to kill they could not
have been more wrong Dr Jones approached
the dense cover of feathers with a pair
of sharpened gardening shears while Dr
Smith opted for a machete at first the
strategy appeared to be working Dr Jones
made several Quick Cuts with feathers
fluttering to the floor and sticking to
the Hazmat suit as Dr Smith slashed into
the feathers with his machete making
similarly promising progress however the
situation quickly took a turn for the
worse when Dr Jones dropped her shears
and let out a blood curdling green the
feathers had taken a little longer to
get through the suit to her skin but
somehow they managed to find a way just
the same Smith grabbed Jones and
attempted to make a break for it but he
was too slow and far too close to the
feathers already the wings wrapped
around them and swallowed them both up
leaving the researchers outside helpless
to do anything but listen to their
screams and wait for them to go quiet
after several minutes they finally did
and now larger scp-469 had officially
claimed another two Foundation Personnel
obviously 469 could not be terminated
using any methods that would place the
responsible Personnel within its grasp
that was simply too risky so the
foundation selected a team of d-class
personnel to attempt to burn the
feathers with an array of flamethrowers
though the feathers were vulnerable to
Fire and began to Blacken and
disintegrate on contact the sound of the
Flames being expelled was loud enough to
feed
scp-469 it growth was so quick in
response to the noise that the fire
could not keep up with the amount of new
feathers and wings being produced by the
same time the flamethrowers ran out of
propellant 469 was the same size it had
been when they started other
terminations have been discussed
including the possibility of submerging
the entire creature in a highly
corrosive acid but so far this has not
yet been attempted whatever they end up
trying it is clear that nothing that
produces a significant amount of noise
will be able to kill 469. so where is it
now what's become of this perverse angel
with the never-ending Wings currently it
is kept in an airtight soundproof
chamber where nothing can trigger the
growth of any more wings so what is it
an angel a demon a twisted mutated bird
of some kind it is entirely possible
that we will never know but it's a
wonderful life had something right even
by accident every time a bell rings
something twisted and deadly though it
may a b gets its wings it was July of
2004 and Bill Murray was enjoying the
peak of an extremely successful career
not only had the iconic actors starred
in some of the most beloved comedies of
the 20th century including Ghostbusters
and Groundhog Day he'd voiced the main
character of the recently released
live-action Garfield movie it'd been a
financial success but it was a critical
flop not that this bothered bill in was
happy with the performance and the
paycheck
what he wouldn't be quite as happy about
was the horrifying encounter he was
about to have with scp-3166
on July 8th bill was enjoying a cold
drink on the porch of his luxurious
Beverly Hills Home the sky was beginning
to darken as the sun set in the west it
was a blissful evening his wife Jennifer
was inside watching TV nothing seemed
particularly out of the ordinary until
he noticed a quick flash of orange in
the distance it was almost too fast to
register this large orange-shaped
darting past the corner of his eye for a
second he entertained the thought that
it might have been an escaped Tiger but
it was gone too fast to really tell Bill
finished his drink and headed inside he
had enough for one night the next
morning he got up to read the paper and
found the Garfield movie getting
slaughtered by the critics one review
stated no one can accuse Garfield the
movie of infidelity to its source it
Faithfully conveys the banality of Jim
Davis's cartoon another called it a film
without energy and without spirit
you put the paper down and ate his
breakfast a few blows to the ego were
worth it for the paydays that came with
big budget family films just then his
wife came to him with a strange question
were you walking around downstairs in
the middle of the night no he hadn't
he'd been sleeping like a baby why did
she ask well Jennifer said I heard some
rustling downstairs last night
sounded like something big
he hadn't heard anything now and told
her it was probably just Her Imagination
he put it out of his mind and continued
about his day he decided he would keep
his eyes peeled for that orange blur
again though Bill didn't see anything
peculiar the rest of the morning and
went to a local cafe for lunch he
ordered a coffee and a cream cheese
bagel then made a quick trip to the
bathroom while his food was prepared
when Bill returned to his table though
there was something strange
instead of a bagel there is a large
heaping of lasagna on the table what was
going on this Cafe didn't even serve
lasagna Bill knew something was terribly
wrong things only got stranger when bill
came home to find a small tuft of orange
fur snagged on the frame of his front
door and it wasn't synthetic for her
like you'd see on plush toys or stuffed
animals no this was real animal fur
maybe someone was just goofing off or
trying to play some weird prank on him
but it didn't feel like it deep down
Bill Murray knew that he was in grave
danger whoever or whatever was behind
this
it wanted to hurt him that night his
worst fears were realized Bill's wife
had left town for the week and he was
headed to the kitchen in the middle of
the night for a glass of water when he
saw something a huge figure moving up
against the glass door leading to his
backyard the thing was huge nearly seven
feet tall with a bloated fur-covered
misshapen body that was pressed up
against the door its fur was bright
garish orange a cartoon or
strangest of all though was the sound it
was making
it sounded like it was purring Bill
backed away from the door and then ran
back to his room to hide the whole night
he sat cowering as he heard scratching
against the walls like something was
trying to get in he was terrified and
too scared to do anything even move
finally as morning broke the noises
seemed to stop Bill had to do something
he couldn't let this nightmare go on
another night what if things got worse
what if that thing managed to get inside
he called the local police and when they
arrived he explained the incredibly
strange situation as best he could he
told them he was being stalked by some
kind of huge cat or at least someone
dressed like a huge cat also there was
lasagna involved the officers
interviewing him could barely contain
their laughter as he told them his story
a giant orange cat perhaps one of them
theorized he angered some kind of
obsessive Garfield fan through his
involvement in the live-action movie
after all the original comic had been
running for years and had been extremely
popular who knows what kind of nut jobs
were obsessed with seeing only a
faithful adaptation of the source
material as the officers departed bill
was confident that they weren't taking
him seriously he couldn't rely on any of
them for protection thankfully from a
multi-decade movie career he had plenty
of disposable income and decided to hire
a private security team to protect him
while he looked into this mystery he had
two trained bodyguards positioned around
his home at all times for the next month
they were armed and given the cryptic
orders to fire on anything orange
meanwhile Bill began to Fall Down A
Garfield Rabbit Hole he felt strangely
compelled to research all the Garfield
media he could find as though the answer
to his terrifying situation was somehow
hidden between the lines Bill explored
the entire backlog of thousands of comic
strips he read the books and interviews
with Jim Davis he watched the cartoons
and straight to DVD animated movies
ironically for a guy who'd recently
trade the lasagna loving orange cat Bill
had never felt quite so immersed in the
character before
he found the strange Pathos in the
routine of Garfield and his friends one
particular comic really piqued his
interest though originally published in
October of 1989 the comic began with
Garfield being woken up by a strange
Chell an almost Eerie sensation the
character observed allowed that he
didn't feel like he was in his own home
he explored his little home further
trying to find his owner John or his
housemate and sometimes Nemesis Odie but
found nothing as Garfield remarked on
feeling alone a purple speechbox
delivered the Sinister message
you have no idea how alone you are
Garfield he then finds that his home
looks like it's been abandoned for years
the for sale sign outside is practically
ancient
Garfield slowly comes to a horrifying
Revelation everyone really is gone and
his adventurers and friends now exist
only in his imagination he's trapped in
a prison of his own creation trying to
Stave off his endless loneliness
in denial about the reality of his
situation the comic ended with a quote
directly from Jim Davis himself saying
an imagination is a powerful tool a
Content memories of the past shade
perceptions of the present or paint a
future so vivid that it can entice or
terrify
all depending upon how we conduct
ourselves today as he read those words
Bill Murray felt a chill down his spine
why had he wanted to get involved in the
Garfield movie in the first place what
had he gotten himself into before he
could slip any deeper into his own mind
Bill heard a faint choked scream
downstairs
he felt his breath catch in his throat
he was terrified but needed to see what
was happening
carefully and quietly began to creep
down the stairs at the bottom he poked
his head around a corner and that's when
he saw a member of his security detail
lying dead on the floor his face was
Blue from asphyxiation his mouth was
stuffed with lasagna
it looked like he had been force-fed to
death
they wanted to scream but he couldn't or
maybe knew he shouldn't just then he
heard a soft meaty thumping noise coming
from the nearby living room he didn't
know why but he felt compelled to
approach as if by forces Beyond his
control he made his way to the living
room and when he'd got there he saw
where the noise was coming from Bill's
jaw dropped in pure horror there was the
other member of his security detail
lying limp and lifeless under a giant
orange figure who was a grotesquely huge
creature wearing what looked to be a
kind of crude Garfield outfit made of
sewn together cat pants it's stank of
pasta and rotten meat in its giant Paw
It held the golden trophy which it was
using to pound the security guard's head
into mush while making quiet cat-like
purring noises the creature suddenly
stopped and looked up locking eyes with
Bill the fear of death came over him he
froze as the giant freakish Garfield
stepped over Donny's corpse and began to
come towards him bill turned and ran but
Garfield was gaining on him before he
could make it to the front door the
creature knocked him over he was laid
out on the ground looking up at it as it
reached into its own body cavity and
began to pull out handfuls of lasagna he
was about to shove a wad of the horrible
decaying pasta into Bill's mouth when
suddenly a ding Was Heard and the
creature stopped
looked up as if sniffing the air and
then suddenly turned and lumbered
towards the kitchen
Bill watched as the Garfield monster
entered the kitchen where somehow there
was a steaming hot fresh lasagna sitting
in the open oven the creature had sensed
the presence of external lasagna and
felt the compulsion to integrate it into
its body grabbing fistfuls and shoving
it into itself
just then a group of highly trained SCP
Foundation Personnel burst into the room
and subdued the creature
had been an ambush the foundation had
been tipped off to the presence of the
creature by monitoring the local police
department dispatches and the report of
a seven foot tall comic book cat
terrorizing a Hollywood actor was
definitely worth looking into the
monster that had almost taken Bill
Murray's life was
scp-3166 a deadly pathophysical being
that tends to manifest around people
somehow involved in the Garfield
intellectual property it appears
whenever the public perception of
Garfield falls out of favor and because
Bill had starred in the critically pan
Garfield movie he was currently at the
very top of
scp-3166's Hit List
thankfully he managed to survive his
terrifying ordeal and was administered
amnestics by Foundation Personnel so
that he could return to his normal life
this frightening and mysterious creature
has been around since 1989 appearing
after the publication of The Haunting
Garfield comic that Bill had read that
very night
it appeared in the office of United
media who were the Publishers of the
Garfield comic strip at the time and
began wrecking Havoc since then the
creature's manifestation has been a
constant threat whenever Garfield loses
its popularity or audience as a result
the foundation has spent years as the
funding source behind all Garfield media
and even planting hypnotic mimetics into
the comic strips to ensure that there is
always a loyal fan base
the fur is indeed real organic cat fur
albeit an unnaturally orange color and
instead of organs the creature is filled
with lasagna worst of all though is that
testing has revealed that the meat in
the lasagna is genetically identical to
the Flesh of Garfield's Creator Jim
Davis how did this thing come into
existence perhaps it was Jim's sheer
force of imagination that dragged it
into being as he himself said an
imagination is a powerful tool all in
all it's lucky that Bill Murray was able
to survive his encounter and return to
his normal life well as normal as life
can be for Bill Murray and if you see
Bill Murray don't bother asking him
about scp-3166
the amnestics were quite effective and
just as he's fond of saying himself
no one will ever believe you in a remote
part of Russia a mysterious disease
outbreak was tearing through a tiny
farming village with terrifying side
effects there was no cure no clue to
where it came from and worst of all the
disease's terrifying impact didn't end
with death no it was after those
carrying the disease died that the real
Horrors started after an agonizing fever
that leaves the victims writhing in pain
they quickly succumbed to the disease
only to rise from their graves to wreak
havoc on the living the virus continues
to spread until the corpses outnumber
those trying to hide from them as the
world spirals into almost certain ruins
it sounds like the plot of a zombie
movie but for the SCP Foundation this is
anything but fiction and the terror that
unfolded in that little Siberian town is
the first recorded encounter with
scp-610 also known as the flesh that
hates first livestock began to vanish
from farms after wild animals were
suspected but no suspects could be found
and no mutilated remains turned up the
animals weren't being stolen and they
weren't being eaten so what happened to
them with no more animals Left to Lose
the farmers themselves then began to
disappear but the authorities refused to
take the missing persons cases seriously
the missing Farmers families would
contact the police make a report and
then the whole thing was forgotten it
was written off just as another unsolved
disappearance which wasn't uncommon in
the wild and unforgiving region then the
police themselves began to disappear the
families of the missing Farmers would
sometimes report strange sounds from the
surrounding Woods describing moans and
inhuman screeches of pain
one young boy reported seeing a cow with
what he described as tentacles lurking
around the edge of the trees Regional
Police were dispatched to the location
in order to investigate and report back
on their findings within 24 hours but
the units sent to the area didn't report
back and were never heard from again
upon learning of the reports the Russian
government grew increasingly concerned
fearing domestic Insurgency or foreign
Espionage of some kind could be at play
they sent a small team of special agents
to the area and one by one those agents
disappeared just like the others before
them it seemed no one who went into the
village after the disappearances started
ever came out again they had all simply
vanished desperate for answers the
Russian government contacted the only
people in the world who could help the
SCP Foundation with the foundation found
over the course of their investigation
would shock and unnerve them going
beyond anything they had previously
discovered before the investigation
officially began the affected area was
sealed off by the Russian government not
knowing if it would be safe to send
researchers into the containment
perimeter the foundation set up a small
camera mounted unit nicknamed Herbie to
capture footage of whatever remained of
the village the images captured by
Herbie revealed what exactly had become
of the people in this Village and the
true nightmarish nature of scp-610
scp-610 is a ketter class entity meaning
it's an anomaly that's exceedingly
difficult to contain consistently or
reliably with containment procedures
often being extensive and complex 610 is
a highly contagious skin disease that
initially manifests like an ordinary
allergic reaction with symptoms
including increased sensitivity itching
and a rash but within just three hours
of those initial symptoms appearing the
rash starts to turn into masses of Scar
Tissue on the chest and arms these
masses spread over the legs and back of
the victim and completely consume them
in thick rubbery flesh within five hours
once they're covered the victim will
cease all vital functions unfortunately
for them and doubly so for those around
them they do not stay Dead about three
minutes after expiring the victim's
vitals will restart at a heightened rate
and the masses of Flesh encasing their
body will begin to move and multiply
mutating them into a form beyond
anything resembling the human they once
were the specific type of mutation
varies from case to case but has
included the head becoming massive in
bulbous the growth of extra limbs and an
especially gruesome cases the victim's
body splitting apart to allow extra
tendrils of Flesh to sprout from the
open wound occasionally an infected
person will stop moving and become
rooted to the ground in a set location
once it is settled their flesh will
spread itself across the ground encasing
all nearby objects and flaps of scar
tissue the infected that maintain their
Mobility are highly aggressive even
violent and will attempt to infect any
living thing that comes into their line
of sight the disease does not only
affect humans and can take over any
living organism within a matter of hours
due to the highly contagious and
dangerous nature of the disease safe
observation of infected specimens and
areas is only possible with drones and
mounted cameras this brings us back to
Herbie the first such mounted camera to
record footage of the infected area
Herbie was deployed to an infection site
also known as site a without any damage
it remained at the outside perimeter of
the village for two hours observing
several infected humans and fire damage
to many of the homes before following an
infected into an intact house Herbie's
camera feed captured the infected person
entering the house and sitting down at
the table inside there were several
other infected humans in the house and
one unidentified infected creature that
remained immobile under the table after
viciously assaulting one of the other
infected humans the infected returned to
the table and began to lay out plates on
top of it pieces of its flesh began to
wriggle and tear away from its body
before set going on to each plate once
the plates were filled the infected
sitting at the table began to grab at
the Flesh and crush it into their mouths
in a perverse imitation of a normal Meal
Time Gathering after capturing this
stomach churning display Herbie left the
house and continued to explore the
village the recorded footage of a large
stack of bodies that seemed to be made
up of both Russian military and
civilians with an infected sitting on
top as Herbie maneuvered towards the
remains of the Town Hall an infected
grabbed the Rover off the ground
Herbie's camera was able to capture the
face of the infected that grabbed the
Rover the face was that of a young girl
around 10 years old strangely intact to
top a large distorted body the final
moments of Herbie's camera feed captured
the infected girl's face bursting open
revealing tendrils of Flesh that pulled
Herbie into the gaping Maw then the feed
cut to Black Herbie was regarded as lost
but the video feed briefly resumed five
hours later showing the camera covered
with an unidentified slime after this
the video feed was cut for good and
Herbie abandoned Insight a the
foundation has sent several manned
Expeditions into side a where many
Expedition forces have fallen victim to
the infected several operatives were
also lost in an earthquake that revealed
a network of underground tunnels a
manned Expedition into these tunnels was
attempted and the video feed that was
captured by the researchers on the
expedition was deeply disturbing there
were images of an abandoned church
filled with infected and a mass of
uninfected or partially infected human
captives
the final moments of the video feed from
this Expedition captured several
operatives being murdered by an infected
human wielding a farming Scythe
indicating that the infected are capable
of using simple Weaponry in addition to
Brute Force the use of this weapon
paired with the presence of captives in
the underground tunnels paints a
terrifying picture of the kind of
organization the infected are capable of
no more manned Expeditions have been
attempted or if they have they have been
highly classified ordinarily once a new
SCP is discovered it is placed in
containment at the foundation with
special procedures in place so that it
can be studied or even neutralized in
the rare occasions where it's deemed
necessary when it comes to scp-610
though containment might just be
impossible it simply covers too much
area and is too dangerous to expose to
human researchers instead all infected
areas have been isolated with the
permission of the Russian government
there is an official perimeter
established around these areas and any
civilians that approach them are told to
leave under the pretense of ongoing
military operations for once a
top-secret military project is the more
innocent answer armed guards are placed
at the perimeter of every infected area
and any living thing with symptoms of
scp-610 spotted near the perimeter is to
be immobilized killed and burned from as
far away as possible any living thing
that comes in contact with scp-610
whether a soldier a scientist or a
civilian is immediately terminated and
their remains destroyed if someone comes
within three meters of an infected
organism they will be quarantined and
remotely examined to determine if they
have been infected while the spread of
scp-610 can be airborne it has been
determined to be far less contagious
when spread through air particles as
opposed to physical contact
the infection sites remain active to
this day like modern day leper colonies
though they are isolated from the
general population and the military is
doing everything in their power to
contain the infected
scp-610 is still very much alive it is
rare for an entity to exist that the
foundation cannot truly contain but can
only try to guard against and that makes
this infection all the more terrifying
who knows how much it has mutated over
the years growing spreading hungry for
new hosts there is still so much that
the foundation does not know about the
flesh that hates such as how it works
what it can do or even where it came
from since the origin of the first
infection is still at this point
entirely unknown it has shown itself to
be capable of learning planning and
protecting itself so who is to say that
it couldn't figure out a way to escape
from its isolated area it is so highly
contagious and spreads so quickly that
just one tiny infected rabbit a and one
inattentive soldier could be enough for
scp-610 to reach the general population
if it did its violent destructive nature
and hatred for all life would mean that
everything not just the people but
animals plants and the world itself
could be at risk and no one is ready for
this kind of infection a disease that
turns the human body against itself
turns our skin into a weapon and a tomb
stripping away identity humanity and
everything that isn't made of the same
hateful flesh so let's hope that the
perimeter holds and the next time you
feel a little itchy try not to think
about what might happen next it's the
holiday season outside it's cold and
there's snow blanketing the ground but
inside your war and gathered around the
light of a roaring fireplace and a
glowing Christmas tree this is what
Christmas is all about warmth joy and
togetherness but just because you're
comfortable doesn't mean you're safe you
were so busy opening presents and
stuffing yourself at dinner that you
didn't notice the face pressed up
against the window that long gone face
with the staring eyes the wide mouth
full of yellow teeth and the scraggly
white beard you don't know it yet but
within a few days you'll be dead you
might be able to avert this horrible
fate if you knew what exactly you were
dealing with
scp-4666 also known as the Yule man a
ketter class Christmas monster so
violent sadistic and terrifying he makes
Krampus look like Jolly Saint Nick and
this year just like every other he's
planning on being very very naughty the
SCP Foundation began cataloging the Yule
man in 1974 after a string of violent
and eerily similar home invasions during
the holiday season but they have reason
to believe that this entity has been
around for a whole lot longer over 2 000
years in fact stories that describe what
look to be Yule man massacres date back
as far as the first century BC in
Scandinavia and there have been reports
of similar clusters of events happening
around the same time every year since
this monster is prolific and may have
one of the highest body counts of any
creature under observation by the
foundation the Yule man's trail of
Destruction became clearer in the 18th
century as accounts of the Carnage it
leaves became more detailed later still
authorities even managed to find
physical evidence like the eule man's
fingerprints which are similar to human
fingerprints but display a distinct
double whirl pattern not seen in human
fingerprints much about the anomalous
nature of the Yule man is still unknown
though and the foundation has yet to
discover an effective way to containment
their only hope is intercepting it
before it can get its long gnarled
fingers on its intended prey maybe
you're feeling worried or that you're
being watched you have good reason to be
afraid because during his yearly active
period the 12 days between December 21st
and January 2nd he's always searching
for prey nowhere is safe because while
it was initially believed that he only
appeared to those who live north of 40
degrees latitude it's now believed that
much like Santa Claus the eule man
operates worldwide anyone could be in
his sights right now blissfully unaware
of The Nightmare coming down the tracks
towards them thankfully the SCP
Foundation through analysts of these
attacks which are known as Vice knocked
the vents they've been able to find
certain patterns but first what does the
creature known as the Yule man even look
like much like scp-096 the Yule man is a
long and lanky humanoid standing about
two meters tall who resembles an
emaciated human of European descent and
never wears any clothes or other
coverings despite the frigid
temperatures he operates in you might be
sad if you're spending Christmas alone
but it at least guarantees you safety
from the Yule man as he only appears at
the homes of families with a child under
the age of eight present he also seems
to favor isolated and Rural locations
and vice knocked events only occur when
there's a healthy covering of snow on
the ground during the event hence the
name which means White Knight in English
it's also vital that you recognize the
three distinct stages of a vice not the
event II or you won't be seeing much of
the new year the first stage occurs
during the space of a week children in
the home might start to seem worried or
afraid they might tell you that they see
something strange in the distance the
figure of a man they don't recognize
standing just far enough away that you
can't fully make him out except that
he's really tall of course you probably
won't see anything and your instinct
will be to tell them there's nothing to
be afraid of even when they tell you
through tears that there's a man
pressing his face up against their
bedroom window at night but they are
right to be afraid and you should be too
already at this point your only hope is
to try and spread the word as soon as
possible report the incident to the
local police write about it on Facebook
tweet about it whatever it takes the SCP
Foundation has operatives trawling the
internet and monitoring police reports
constantly during this period especially
for reports of mysterious men in the
snow watching homes from a distance
getting the foundation's attention is
your best hope of stopping this thing
and if you don't next comes stage two
taking place between Knights 8 and 11 of
the active period no longer will the
Yule man just be lurking on the
periphery now he's getting closer you'll
start to hear strange noises in your
attic or on the roof noises that sound
almost like footsteps that's crazy you
think it's probably just an animal but
then the smell starts an awful rotten
stench that fills the house but no
matter how hard you look you can't find
the source finally on the last night of
December you'll tell yourself that
you'll take this matter to the police
but of course it's already too late the
Yule man is here for the 12th night the
vice knocked is finally upon you at this
point one of two scenarios will happen
in the first you and your entire family
will be tortured and murdered except the
youngest child who the eule man will
kidnap the SCP Foundation keeps files on
a number of notable instances of this
kind of ice
and the details are truly gruesome
reports of incidents have involved
crucifixion the removal of tongues
burning dismemberment post-mortem bite
marks and decapitation in all instances
though the entire family was killed
except the youngest child who simply
disappeared the eule man is a merciless
and sadistic Beast you're now probably
wondering if that's the first of two
Vice knock possibilities what's the
second in the second if you're
tremendously lucky you and your family
will survive but that doesn't mean you
won't face a grisly experience in this
scenario which occurs during about 15
percent of ice knocked events you'll
hear footsteps throughout the night but
thankfully you wake up alive and when
you do so there are gifts waiting for
you the problem is all these gifts are
made out of human body parts for example
in 1976 in Canada one family received
the gift of a ball made from a severed
human head wrapped in skin in Kazakhstan
in 1903 a family received a flute made
from a hollowed-out human femur and in
the Netherlands in 2003 a family
received a wooden hairbrush covered in
human teeth ranging from 400 years old
to a mere few days these gruesome gifts
are referred to as
scp-4666-a and it was one of these gifts
that gave us the best Insight yet
available into the true nature of the
Yule man several gifts were dropped off
at a family's residence in Huna Alaska
in 2018 but most notably among them was
the horrific
scp-466-a-0960 a life-sized doll made
from a human body with its eyes removed
and mouth-sewn shut worst of all though
was that the girl was still alive the
family who received this Twisted gift
was given a me sticks by the foundation
and the living doll was taken for
medical treatment before succumbing to
her extensive injuries the girl was able
to deliver some insights into what
exactly happened to the children who
were abducted during Vice knocked events
the children taken by the Yule man are
forced into a large sack that seems much
bigger on the inside than it appears as
he makes his rounds traveling from house
to house murdering and kidnapping his
victims are taken to a kind of
underground Grotto and workshop filled
with bones like a twisted Santa's
Workshop where they're forced to make
toys out of the bodies of their fellow
victims during this time the Yule man
will continue to torture and torment his
victims he'll even take some of them
away to cook and eat whenever he feels
like it when asked how she was turned
into this human doll the girl told
Foundation Personnel that her fellow
victims were forced to turn her into
this by the Yule man when she became too
weak to continue making toys herself her
chilling last words were when you can't
make the toys you become the toy
so if strange things happen to you and
your family between the 21st of December
and the 1st of January don't ignore it
after all you never know who's watching
but if it is the eule man's grinning
face pressed up against your window it
may already be too late happy holidays
there is a dangerous creature that could
be anywhere in the world hiding in plain
sight casually walking through crowded
streets filled with people a monster
that is nearly impossible to see
blending into its surroundings almost
perfectly Not Invisible but unnoticeable
almost completely undetectable but then
you spot a familiar outfit in a crowd
you now know where the creature is but
it goes both ways since the moment you
find it it knows where you are there is
now not a single place on the earth that
you could hide where it wouldn't find
you and it won't ever stop looking
staff at the foundation this creature is
known as
scp-4885 but you and I know him by a
different name you may have seen this
face hundreds of times or stared for
hours at a page trying to catch a
glimpse of him to us he's Waldo while
this might feel like a very long-winded
and silly joke maybe even a prank that
has been inserted into the SCP archives
it is anything but if you grew up
anytime after the late 1980s then you
will likely be familiar with the where's
Waldo books but for the uninitiated
there are a series of puzzle books
created by illustrator Martin Hanford
each book in the where's Waldo line
contains multiple double page spreads of
colorful crowded scenes the goal is for
readers to spot the ever elusive titular
character Waldo who is hidden among the
mass of other characters Waldo himself
is easily recognized thanks to a design
line that has become truly iconic over
the years he is always depicted as
wearing a red and white striped shirt
with a bobble hat and matching colors
Waldo also Sports jeans circular rimmed
glasses and sometimes a wooden walking
stick so with that important context out
of the way up front what exactly is
scp-4885 is the character from these
children's books somehow brought to life
has the character of Waldo always been a
malicious malevolent entity too powerful
to be contained within his own books
well not exactly
scp-4885 only seems to resemble the
famous children's book character whether
or not he is the living manifestation of
Waldo in the real world is both unclear
and Up For Debate examining its outward
appearance
scp-4885 does share the humanoid shape
and looks to be wearing the same
recognizable clothing of Waldo there are
however two notable bodily
dissimilarities between the Waldo and
page and the physical form of
scp-4885 for one this Waldo appears to
be much paler to the one found in the
book series more noticeably however is
the fact despite wearing the same
circular glasses
scp-4885 seems to have no eyes should a
person learn of
scp-4885's current location Waldo will
simultaneously gain an awareness of this
person learning instantly of their
victim's location
scp-4885 will Traverse any space
necessary tracking their target down to
anywhere they might be in the world the
creatures displayed a number of space
altering abilities including
teleportation
scp-4885 can also alter the state of his
own matter allowing Waldo to phase
through solid surfaces no obstacle can
stop his Advance not walls not buildings
not even his victim's own body when SCP
4885 finally reaches the person who has
learned of his location Waldo will then
proceed to murder them in an
exceptionally excruciating manner using
his matter changing abilities he will
teleport or phase himself inside his Vic
pulling himself through their body and
destroying their internal organs after
causing catastrophic bodily damage
scp-4885 will then wrench their victim's
jaw open unhinging it with enough Force
to climb his way out of their mouth
leaving them dead their body completely
mangled however this isn't even the
final stage of Waldo's attack there is a
strange byproduct left after a fatal
encounter with
scp-4885 a yellow liquid that is
produced as Waldo exits his victim's
body when this substance comes into
contact with the deceased person's skin
it triggers a bizarre change the liquid
will cause their bodies to change after
death their skin becoming covered in
symbols on closer inspection it becomes
clear that these symbols are
illustrations exactly like the ones
found in the pages of where's Waldo
these corpses referred to by the
foundation as instances of scp-4885-1
will then start to act in a similar
manner to
scp-4885 and anyone who sees one or
learns of its location will cause Waldo
to come looking for them the where's
Waldo scenes left on a deceased victim's
skin cannot be washed off or otherwise
removed and the only way to undo an
instance of
scp-4885-1 is to skin an infected body
after death however this creates a whole
new problem if someone was to attempt
this in doing so they would know the
location of one of Waldo's victims this
knowledge would mean that whomever was
trying to skin one of these bodies would
themselves become Waldo's next Target
and would likely end up just another
instance of scp-4885-1
in other words it would be an exercise
in futility naturally the nature of
visibilities and attack patterns make it
difficult for the SCP Foundation to
contain Waldo
scp-4885 cannot be harmed through the
use of firearms or other common
Conventional Weapons at the foundation's
disposal you might be forgiven for
thinking that making a handful of people
aware of where to find Waldo at the same
time would be a viable solution after
all he cannot be in multiple places at
once so perhaps he'd be unable to kill
these individuals simultaneously however
scp-4885 has shown to be able to cope
with this approach dispatching his
victims one at a time transforming each
and turn into where's Waldo printed
corpses before continuing to the next
would-be victim if the victim is nearby
Waldo will force himself into their
mouth passing through their body and
destroying bones organs and even the
spinal column when victim is further
away Waldo will phase through the
nearest wall and attack them teleporting
into his Target and then climbing out of
their mouth Waldo's location or that of
his victim's bodies are considered info
hazards simply being aware of this
information will cause
scp-4885 to activate as a result of this
the staff at the SCP Foundation are not
even sure that Waldo is actually
contained at all in theory
scp-4885 is being held at an undisclosed
Foundation site within a non-designed
containment chamber since even a number
on the door would tip off what's inside
triggering while those abilities but
here's The Clincher because nobody can
know for sure where Waldo is without him
coming for them nobody at the foundation
actually knows where he's being
contained if he's even retained at all
it is worth noting that if someone
receives a vague non-specific
description of Waldo's whereabouts that
he will make no attempt to seek them out
if he is contained and if he was to ever
breach containment then the SCP
Foundation has an entire set of
procedures in place to ensure that no
one ever finds Waldo first 36
containment Chambers identical to the
one
scp-4885 is supposedly held in are
connected to a self-driving vehicle an
Expendable d-class Personnel member is
placed into the vehicle and a random
number generator will select a number
from 1 to 36. the self-driving vehicle
will then arrive at the containment
chamber chosen at random and the class
placed inside within each chamber are
digital monitors and once the d-class is
inside the chamber all of these monitors
will display the current location of
scp-4885 the foundation has kept a GPS
tracking device implanted within Waldo
but this information is normally kept
secret to avoid any containment breaches
the d-class essentially acts as bait for
Waldo forcibly given the knowledge of
his location so that
scp-4885 will consider them a Target as
part of the next phase of containment
Foundation staff Will Wait giving Waldo
enough time to arrive in the containment
chamber and dispatch the d-class within
after this all of the 36 containment
Chambers are transported to random
Foundation sites in disguised trucks so
that no one is sure where
scp-4885 ends up every time
scp-4885 breaches containment the entire
procedure has to be repeated the
foundation first encountered SCP 48.85 a
number of years ago inside a small
wooden house the exact location of which
has since been expunged from all the SCP
foundation's records while on assignment
to secure an entirely different anomaly
the foundation's mobile task force chai
19 also codenamed unrelenting punishment
were the first to discover Waldo the
three-person unit consisted of
foundation operatives named Amelia
Merrick James Klein and Kurt Stahl the
trio cautiously entered the wooden house
where they were meant to investigate
reports of an anomalous inanimate object
a pair of black spectacles according to
initial intelligence gathered by the SCP
Foundation these glasses were capable of
killing anyone that tried to wear them
leaving their body covered in pictures
like those found in the children's book
sounds familiar doesn't it it is unknown
if these black spectacles are the same
eyewear worn by
scp-4885 but it doesn't seem like too
far of a leap to assume that this may
well have been the case searching the
ground floor of the team had found no
sign of the object they had been sent to
recover as Amelia Kurt and James made
their way upstairs something began
making scraping sounds beneath them but
none of them noticed in an abandoned
bedroom on the upstairs floor of the
house Kurt spotted a drawing on the wall
which looked to have been made using
crayons he took a photo of the
illustration and this image is still
kept in the foundation's database it
appears to be a child's drawing
depicting
scp-4885 wearing his signature striped
shirt and hat with empty vacant eyes
next to it was scrawled one simple
phrase Waldo found mommy continuing
their way through the house the team
located the glasses they were looking
for in an upstairs bathroom however as
James bagged up the spectacles ready for
transport back to the foundation Kurt
spotted another inscription on the
nearby wall one that the team were
certain hadn't been there when they had
arrived James stepped in to train
enslaved using the foundation standard
issue translation device the phrase on
the wall red the basement the corpses
from a child's book are in the basement
he is there too for and we're sure that
you can already guess what happened
after that immediately after reading
these words James began to groan and
clutched at his stomach showing signs of
extreme pain before Amelia recurred had
any chance to figure out what was
happening to their squad mate fingers
began protruding from James's mouth they
gripped his jaw and pulled it apart with
enough Force to send his Jawbone flying
across the room
scp-4885 climbed its way out of James's
body and Amelia and Kurt both opened
fire on the creature Waldo did not react
seemingly unfazed by the gunfire and
sustaining no damage as he approached
Amelia who would be his next victim
shoving his fingers into her throat
Waldo wrenched apart Amelia's jaw
breaking it before he clawed his way
into her mouth as he watched in Horror
kurd made a panicked call for help to
the foundation but it was too late Waldo
had already dispatched both James and
Amelia and now Kurt was about to pay the
same terrible Price ever since this
incident the foundation believes that
they have
p4885 contained when his file was
created the researchers created an
automated algorithm designed to wipe
away any mention of
scp-4885's current location or the house
he was discovered in from Foundation
records with scp-4885 now assumed to be
contained that only leaves one question
the same burning inquiry that's been
plaguing man for decades where's Waldo
in this case maybe it's safer if you
didn't no you're a pizza delivery person
for a company we're not at Liberty to
name it may seem like a thankless job
but you're part of the thin cross
between satisfaction and starvation for
people who really don't feel like
cooking or going out tonight you're a
tried and true Pizza veteran you 've
seen a lot on the job from people who
try to rob you on their own doorsteps to
one guy who tried to tip you with a
clearly fake Rolex but you haven't seen
anything like the insanity you're about
to encounter tonight that's because
you're about to get sick really really
sick and we know there's probably a lot
of diseases you'd rather not catch but
trust us no disease bites quite like
scp-3760 but back to you you're parked
on the saddle of your prize bicycle
pedaling for your life the biggest order
you've ever delivered strapped to the
cargo rack behind you eight large Meat
Feast pizzas you figure you're heading
towards the most hopping or at least the
hungriest party in the city and despite
the frustration of needing to Ferry this
hot cheesy nightmare to its destination
parties have historically been pretty
good tippers little do you know your
prize customer is about to give you much
more than just a tip you pull outside
their ground level apartment and park
your bike there's no music coming from
the apartment you're heading to strange
you pick up your precious cargo and
trudge towards the door barely managing
to ring the bell with your spare Pinky
the door swings open instantly as though
the occupant was just standing behind it
the whole time waiting for you when the
door opens you're not sure what to make
of what you see inside there isn't a
party there doesn't even seem to be a
group just one person standing there and
staring at you and something about this
person is just wrong his skin seems to
be an oddly unnatural color it has a
slightly gray Hue like it's rotting and
you see that the stranger's shirt is
torn in several places you're trying
your best to remain professional and not
stare but you notice that whatever is
under these tears doesn't look like skin
it's almost like there are holes all
over his body underneath the shirt big
gaping holes and are those you're cut
off when he takes the pile of pizzas
from you and shoves what was once a
handful of dollars into your palm they
seem torn up and worst of all wet you
look past your strange customer and see
that his apartment looks just as shoddy
as he does there's stuffing torn from
the couch huge tears in the curtains
when you could swear or scratch your
bite marks on some of the wooden
furniture this man clearly needed his
pizza as you begin to step away happy to
just be rid of this freaky situation you
do something that you'll live to regret
just for a moment you lock eyes with the
customer there's something about them
that makes you feel sick they're wet and
black more like a doll's eyes than
anything that should belong to a human
just that one instant of contact is
enough to chill your bones and according
to some theories around
scp-3760 it may have been the moment of
your infection as the stranger closes
the door in your face presumably to eat
his obscene number of pizzas stumble
back to your bicycle letting your torn
up Gooey tip Blow Away In The Wind
getting out of this place is rewarding
enough but you can't chase the thoughts
of the stranger out of your mind was he
sick was he even human these are the
thoughts swimming through your head as
you cycle back to the restaurant you're
so preoccupied you don't even notice the
truck speeding towards you you get
sideswiped destroying your bike and
throwing you in the air you can feel the
snap of your arm breaking as you land
it's a horrible feeling to go along with
the horrible noise and as you fade from
Consciousness the last thought in your
mind is the black soulless eyes of the
customer when you wake up you'll find
that you're in a hospital bed with your
arm in a cast The Doctors tell you that
you're phenomenally lucky to be alive
given the severity of the crash the
doctor says that you're dealing with a
compound fracture in your right arm as
well as some nasty cuts that required
stitches but otherwise you're fine the
hospital insists that you at least stay
the night though and you you oblige but
that night you find it's difficult to
sleep partially because of the pain but
mostly because of an extremely strange
sound coming from inside the cast around
your arm it's a scraping noise like
something sharp scratching at the
interior you figure it must just be some
strange side effect of the pain meds
you're not going to let worry eat you up
on the inside something else will be
doing that soon enough your discharge
from the hospital the next day and told
that you should be fine in a couple of
months as though that's some kind of
consolation you try to carry on with
your daily life as much as you can with
one arm out of commission but that awful
crunching noise from inside your cast
persists you even start to become
paranoid that some sort of insect is
trapped inside or worse a swarm of
insects but you aren't left without
uncertainty for Long by the next morning
your cast has fallen off will not Fallen
per se a more accurate a description
would be that it was chewed off from the
inside and not by something trapped in
there with your arm but by your arm
itself when you finally see it it
doesn't even look like an arm anymore
the flesh has turned gray that same
sickly gray of the customer's skin the
night of your accident but worse still
from the top of the hand down to the
base of the forearm your entire arm is
split open into a Fang line chattering
mouth when you've gotten over the
initial horror of seeing the mutations
that have taken hold of your arm you
notice something about the teeth in the
second mouth they're nothing like human
teeth their vicious Jagged triangles
each one like a dagger these are
unmistakably shark's teeth you give
yourself the luxury of having a good
screen after all what else are you
supposed to do after you find your arm
as turned into some kind of fleshy shark
mutant you notice that you can hardly
even feel the snapping of its jaws like
it isn't even really a part of you and
as much as you try to tencent release
what used to be the tendons in your
forearm there is no change for all
intents and purposes that limb is no
longer yours it just happens to be
attached to you not only that but it's
always very very hungry as quickly
became evident from the fact it made
such short work of the cast that had
been containing it not long ago you can
see that the graying flesh is beginning
to spread from your forearm to your
bicep it's almost like little by little
your tissue is being switched somehow
you're innately aware that if you don't
feed your arm it'll get even worse
suddenly everything about the strange
customer from the night of the accident
makes sense he had whatever you have now
only worse he was just hoping that the
pizzas would keep the beast at Bay and
you very much hope the contents of your
fridge will do the same wasting no time
you grab some processed ham and raw
chicken you're not an idiot you know
that if this thing is anything like a
real shark it's only going to be
interested in meat but when you shove
the processed meat into the nibbling maw
in your forearm you notice that it seems
to spit the food out something tells you
that your offering was too dead now
you're really afraid will this thing
want life prey will that be the only way
to stop it from taking the rest of your
arm or even more the thought terrifies
you it's like being Venom except you
don't even get a new alien friend or any
cool superpowers for your trouble but
you're smart you're resourceful you
don't intend to let this thing take over
your life without a fight and you've
always believed what GI Joe taught you
knowing is half the battle sadly doing
an internet search for my injury is
somehow mutating into a shark how do I
stop this didn't do much good and you
don't want to go to a doctor because
part of you expects to be immediately
shipped off to the nearest circus or
military research lab instead you throw
on a thick leather jacket that you hope
your new shark arm will take a while to
eat through and head to the library of
the nearest Medical College if anywhere
has sources on the most obscure of
medical problems this would be the place
and after hours of searching through
index cards you find it what seems to be
the one and only source of this
ludicrous Topic in the thousands and
thousands of books a series of journal
entries made by Dr Keith Woodward ship's
medical officer aboard the USS Kirby
Circa 1922 even the library's indexing
system prefaces the source with a
disclaimer that it's likely 25 quackery
and 75 ocean Madness but that doesn't
deter you and he poured in the storm Dr
Woodward told the horrifying tale of the
USS Kirby's collapse due to a sudden and
unexplainable contagion it began with
the infection of a sailor on the ship
named Willis Riggs who'd Fallen
overboard and had his foot partially
eaten by a shark much like your arm the
man's foot slowly became the ravenous
all-devouring mouth of a shark itself
little by little it spread to the other
crew members through unknown means any
injuries sustained by the crew didn't
heal like normal but instead became this
vicious living shark tissue soon these
ever-hungry new mouths LED them to eat
each other and then themselves from the
inside out even after the humans they
once were could be considered long dead
those hungry Jaws kept snapping there
was no cure there was no solution
everyone on the boat was recorded as
having mysteriously died at Sea that is
the curse of
scp-3760 and as if On Cue you look down
to see that the shark's mouth in your
arm has chewed through the leather of
your sleeve like it's nothing it's
hungry and nothing will satiate it but
perhaps some sacrifices need to be made
if you want to stop it from getting
worse just as the thought crosses your
mind a needle full of sedative is
injected into your neck everything goes
dark very quickly and when you wake up
you're in a clean clinical white room
you are now a officially under
containment by the SCP Foundation not
that you'll know that anytime soon this
may seem like the calvary has arrived
but sadly for your sake they have no
interest in curing you they're just
eager to gather more data on how your
condition progresses
scp-3760 exists as a latent infection in
well over half of humanity but its
horrific mutating effects are activated
in only a relative few there have only
been 2785 recorded cases of scp-3760
activity observed between 1958 and
2016. this is thanks to the foundation's
secret weapon against the shark mutation
Menace subliminal memetic age and Kappa
Omicron or smako a widely distributed
memetic agent that suppresses the
symptoms of infection in most people not
that this would provide much comfort to
you as you join the almost 3 000 others
who have been infected and you are
doomed to slowly turn into an
abomination in your your containment
chamber if it's any consolation you may
not see the truly Advanced stages of the
disease the most common cause of death
Among The Afflicted is being eaten by
their own ravenous shark mouths long
before it changes your entire body
actually come to think of it that's not
much of a consolation at all but hey
when it comes to anomalous mutations
we're sad to report that there's rarely
a happy ending in store for those
Afflicted and
scp-3760 is no exception to the rule why
do so many of the indigenous cultures of
the colder regions of North America seem
to share the same Legend a legend that
tells of a monster that lurks in the
forests bringing cold and death to any
that meet it this creature is an omen of
famine a territorial Beast that preys on
human beings some cultures describe it
as an Unholy Abomination a spirit of
winter and a warning against the dangers
of selfishness one that is created
whenever a person resorts to cannibalism
in order to survive it will gladly
devour any man woman or child that
wanders into its territory holding a
horrifying and insatiable hunger for
human flesh so how did so many cultures
end up with the same story could it be
because it's real depictions of the
Beast vary but it is most commonly
recognized by its tall skeletal form
like a body exhumed from the grave even
carrying the stench of death and Decay
with it anyone who encounters one risks
being eaten or transformed into a
creature just like it the monster's name
means an evil spirit that devours
mankind though to even say the name is
taboo as it's believed to give power to
the Beast of course these are all just
Legends right stories to warn against
the dangers of greed and selfishness but
otherwise nothing to fear there's no
proof that such a beast could actually
be roaming the Frozen wastes many at the
SCP Foundation and felt the same way
until they heard about
scp-323 the wendigo's skull kept under
lock and key by the foundation with
around-the-clock surveillance
scp-323 is an anomalous object with ties
to the various wendigo Legends as the
object's moniker suggests
scp-323 is a skull not a human skull
mind you it more closely resembles a
servid skull cervids are a family of
mammals that include most varieties of
deer elk and other similar animals and
this particular servant skull Sports a
tall pair of antlers
scp-323 is definitely not a fresh skull
either it shows signs of weathering and
a few scars across the surface looking
as if the bone has been bleached and
eroded through exposure to the elements
the skull is also missing its lower jaw
and has a sizable hole on the rear
Underside that may have been carved
using stone tools
scp-323 is kept restrained inside an
armored container Within in a concrete
containment cell and Personnel are only
ever allowed near it to check the
restraints for signs of damage
additionally any foundation staff that
enter scp-323 cell must be accompanied
by an armed security officer and in the
event of the containment breach the
entire site is to be evacuated seems
like a lot of precautions and safety
measures for an old piece of bone surely
a harmless deer skull could never be
that dangerous right wrong you might be
forgiven for thinking that a skull can't
possibly cause harm after all
scp-323 is just a skull then whatever
animal it belonged to is dead but this
skull is far more than it appears to be
through extensive testing the SCP
foundation's researchers have learned
that the skull isn't dead no this skull
is awake and aware it can see hear and
has a sense of touch and it can and will
react to various stimuli however this
does not necessarily mean that scp-323
is alive or even sentient but it
definitely appears to have some level of
sapience it will Target certain members
of personnel that get too close and has
attempted multiple times to breach
containment it also reacts violently to
anyone speaking English or French near
it the only two languages prohibited
inside
scp-323 cell so while the skull is not
technically alive it is definitely aware
still why the need for so many protocols
to keep it contained it's not as if a
skull can just walk off on its own of
course not but scp-323 can move at least
to a certain degree often in a
reactionary manner scp-323 will vibrate
or move on its own for example turning
to watch as Personnel enter its
containment cell in most cases these
movements are tiny and insignificant but
other times the skull lunges launching
itself at Foundation in personnel as it
desperately tries to get free now you
know why it's kept restrain so we have
an antlered servant skull that can move
and has a low level of awareness on
their own these would be more than
enough to Warrant the foundation's
interest but the anomalous properties of
scp-323 don't stop there the skull has
an inherent ability to influence the
minds of those around it anyone spending
an hour within a 15 meter radius of
scp-323 is likely to experience the
effects of this influential power this
will often result in them exhibiting
uncharacteristic behaviors thoughts and
urges including cannibalistic Tendencies
and outbursts of random violence almost
three quarters of people that suffer the
influence of scp-323 will feel an
overwhelming compulsion to take the
wendigo skull and fit their heads into
the chiseled hole on the rear Underside
if someone attempting this finds that
their head is too big to fit inside the
hollow of skull there have been cases of
individuals trying to bludgeon their
heads on any hard surface they can find
nearby in an attempt to get their head
down to a more manageable size this will
continue until one of three outcomes
occurs one the person manages to fit
their head into the skull two they cause
themselves so much cranial damage that
they are rendered unconscious for three
they end up killing themselves through
repeated violent head trauma of course
if a person actually manages to fit
their head inside
scp-323 then that is a different story
entirely in these instances the
individual becomes classified as an
instance of
scp-323-1 within 10 minutes of wearing
the skull this person will suffer
dramatic changes to their body any and
all body fat will be rapidly shed as
their hair also begins to fall out
leaving them looking starved and almost
skeletal in appearance their distal
phalanges those are the bones at the tip
of the fingers will elongate and rupture
the skin as they become bony claw-like
appendages the subject will also find
that their teeth have grown abnormally
long and sharp while their limbs will
blacken as if they were suffering
frostbite symptoms along with their
external Transformations
scp-323-1 will also get increased
strength and heightened resistance to
pain they aren't invulnerable though and
can still sustain damage and injuries
scp-323 will also have a dramatic change
happen to their metabolism which will
occur a few minutes into the physical
transformation the subject will now need
an almost constant intake of calories
which if they don't receive will cause
them to starve almost instantly with the
transformation process complete the new
instance of scp-323-1 has finally become
the wendigo a terrifying monster with
one goal to feed the scp-323 instance
will seek out any human beings it can
find so that it can feed upon their
flesh those who have witnessed the 323
instance in the midst of a Feeding
Frenzy have described the way it
violently slaughtered any person it
could find leaving only a mess of blood
as it devoured them their screams mixed
in with the sounds of Bones crunching in
the times that the creature cannot find
a human to nourish its monstrous
appetite it will try to keep itself
alive any way it can sometimes it will
slow down its movement to try and
conserve energy other times it will
ration whatever food is available to it
saving some of its last meal for a
leftover snack and on occasion the
monster will engage in autocannibalism a
form of cannibalism that involves eating
parts of itself humans certainly seem to
be its preferred food source though even
when other sources of meat would be
easier to acquire
scp-323-1 will Zero in on human beings
and will do anything it can to make a
person its neck meal when chasing down
its prey human or otherwise
scp-323-1 has been observed uttering
phrases either spoken in the primary
language of whoever was transformed by
the skull or in the Severn Ojibwe
Potawatomi and Cree languages these are
all Native languages of the numerous
indigenous creatures that shared Legends
of the wendigo where do the phrases come
from though are they another side effect
of scp-323's influence or do they
originate from the skull itself the
foundation's researchers are still
trying to figure that out and at the
moment they have no clues as to where
they come from in one Containment Breach
in 2006 during which an instance of
scp-323-1 was able to kill and devour 12
members of foundation Personnel on-site
surveillance recorded audio of the
creatures speaking
changing
it rasp while dragging a body behind it
after this the sound of a wet cracking
noise was recorded possibly one of the
victim's bones being broken by
scp-323-1 so it could get to the marrow
inside the 323-1 instance does at times
seem to try and resist the influence of
the wendigo skull additional recordings
capture the creature saying
the creature then said followed by
noises of it eating the body
it seems that even the wendigo has its
own internal struggles perhaps showing
that there is still something left of
the human who put on the skull and that
deep down they are fighting against
their cannibalistic impulses but where
exactly did the foundation find scp-323
and is it really the skull of an actual
wendigo the famous creature from North
American Legend in 1997 the SCP
Foundation sent a Detachment to bitteren
Lake in Saskatchewan Canada there had
been reports of a local community
murdering individuals and leaving their
bodies in the forest to appease a
dangerous creature residing nearby this
creature as it was later discovered was
an instance of
scp-323-1 someone had found the skull
and succumbed to its influence placing
it on their head and turning into a
monster ever since the locals had been
killing people and offering up their
dead bodies as sustenance fearful of
what would happen if they didn't after
being brought up with Legends of the
wendigo SCP Foundation agents were able
to capture the Beast however died of
starvation while being transported back
to containment they also covered up the
recent deaths in the area by giving the
local residents amnestics and creating a
cover story about an unidentified serial
killer prior to this James namagos a
local man who was involved in the
murders was brought in for questioning
he remained oddly calm when interviewed
but admitted he had helped move the
bodies that were being offered up as
food for scp-323-1 or as he called it
the wendigo according to James a local
story among the cree people told of men
who had once tried to control a wendigo
and perhaps even tame it through
offerings of food whether or not James
and his fellow locals had the same
intention their primary concern was
keeping themselves safe he described
first encountering the creature a warped
man walking out of the woods killed our
friends right in front of us sometimes
it would stare more than it would make
to kill try to talk to you it whispered
at me pay me Stone come and eat it made
me cold in my bones as the interview
continued James claimed that he felt
like he understood this warped man he
described feeling like the wendigo was
encouraging him to kill that the
creature would help him pass when his
own time came James told the foundation
doctor questioning him that he had heard
the creature in his mind and he felt it
watching him almost constantly Mr namugu
stated that he hoped in killing people
as offerings to the wendigo that his own
family would be spared like the other
locals James namagos was given amnestics
to forget all about the creature and the
murders he'd played a part in committing
so far none of the foundation's staff
had of experienced any similar
behavioral effects to those James
described those who work closely with
scp-323 or have witnessed an instance of
scp-323-1 have felt the creature
communicating with them or urging them
to kill on its behalf ultimately who is
to say
scp-323 is the skull of a wendigo like
those from Legends it certainly seems
like it is but with no way to tell
exactly how old the skull is perhaps
it's actually the reverse and it was the
Wendigo legend that spawned from
instances of
scp-323-1 that were first encountered by
indigenous North American cultures
hundreds of years ago one thing is for
certain if you ever come across a skull
with tall antlers you should try to
resist putting it on otherwise you might
not be feeling like yourself for much
longer it was the summer of 2012 in
Damascus and for the people of Syria it
certainly seemed like all the
predictions about the end of the world
were coming true the Syrian Civil War
was raging between multiple Rebel groups
and the dictator Bashar al-assad whose
government was shelling its own people
as well as using chemical weapons and
brutal campaigns of violence across the
country in hopes of quelling the
Rebellion lit little did they know
admits to all this pain and bloodshed
something even more dangerous was
brewing an anomalous phenomenon in the
sunny Plains north of Damascus that may
pose a threat to all of humanity someday
a threat known to the SCP Foundation as
scp-3989 the bone Orchard this temporal
and spatial anomaly was discovered a few
years earlier in 2009 before the Syrian
Civil War even officially began it's
strange for a highly dangerous
ketterclass anomaly to be discovered
under such seemingly mundane
circumstances the SCP Foundation first
became aware of
scp-3989 after a small Olive Orchard
owner sold a strangely high amount of
Olives that shouldn't have been possible
when compared to his reported number of
Olea europea olive trees field agents
were dispatched to question the owner
about his sudden success but he was
resistant to questioning the agents
began a covert surveillance Opera
operation to figure out what was
actually going on here at which point
they discovered a considerable spatial
anomaly the olive Orchard was Far bigger
on the inside the property was seized by
the foundation for containment the owner
had no real knowledge of the spatial
anomaly it's likely he just decided not
to look a gift horse in the mouth while
making money hand over fist from the
extra olives he sold the owner was given
amnestics and a new life as the
foundation began to study this anomaly
which was now labeled
scp-3989 to this day no researcher has
been able to figure out the origin of
3989's anomalous qualities it was first
given a Euclid class designation and
cordon off from the public with a simple
chain-link fence while Foundation
investigations were underway on the
inside on a map the plot of land the
olive Farm should occupy is about five
square acres but this plot contains an
unseen portal to a pocket Dimension
within its 12 meter active Zone which
doesn't fall follow the same spatial
laws that our reality does this
subdimension known as
scp-3989-a is a hotbed of fascinating
anomalous activity upon discovery of
this Hot Zone the foundation established
the nearby area 126 as a research center
and a makeshift containment facility for
any anomalous entities captured from
scp-3989-a it seemed like the foundation
really had a handle on this situation
but they were blissfully unaware of the
true Horrors lurking with an
scp-3989-a but they'd soon find out in
the most horrifying way possible Dr
farakazali was assigned to head the
research into the anomalous Zone within
3989 and naturally he began organizing
fact-finding Expeditions Into the Heart
of the affected area the first guinea
pig to head into The Hot Zone was former
Foundation agent Hosea Herrick who'd
been demoted to the lowly d-class
position of
d-126-15 due to fail failures on a
previous Mission with a remote link to
Dr gazelli Herrick was forced to venture
into the active anomalous Zone to
collect footage and samples of the Flora
and Fauna within the first thing Herrick
noticed on his expedition was the
strange quality of the olive trees
within the active Zone The Bark was a
stark white and the leaves a bloody red
up close her could see that the Trunks
and branches of the trees had undergone
a process known as ossification where
the material slowly becomes bone or
bone-like tissue hence the anomaly's
creepy name the bone Orchard these
ossified trees became known as
scp-3989-1 Herrick also made another
Discovery all over the trees and ground
were worm-like creatures that looked
like long maggots that the foundation
dubbed
scp-3989-1a agent Herrick then noticed
something was off about the leaves of
the ossified trees they were beating he
looked closer and they appeared to be
heart tissue filled with pumping veins
Dr gazelli ordered Herrick to take a
branch for testing and when he did the
tree began to bleed when he looked down
he saw that the worm-like creatures that
covered the ground were now crawling up
his legs ignoring orders from Dr gazelli
Herrick fled from the active Zone in
Terror as he left Dr gazelli caught
something in the corner of herrick's
body cam footage a long white hind limb
disappearing behind a tree back in our
normal Dimension tests on the sample
hair collected yielded more upsetting
discoveries genetically the trees were
identical to humans the trunks were
human bone and the leaves really were
made of human heart tissue fascinated
and just a little bit horrified Dr
gazelle authorized further Expeditions
into
3989-a this time though agent Herrick
would be accompanied by another d-class
and both would be armed with handguns
and protective body armor as it would
turn out this Expedition would be even
more horrifying than the first as the 2D
classes explored the active zones to
collect further samples they found that
the worms were responsible for the
ossification of the otherwise
non-anomalous olive trees they consumed
the wood little by little and deposited
human bone matter in return Herrick and
His companion also noticed that these
trees were beginning to bear fruit Dr
gazelli ordered Herrick to collect some
of this fruit for testing but when they
attempted to remove the fruit it burst
releasing more worm creatures it seemed
that the converted trees acted as
incubators for their egg sacs before the
duo could return with the samples they
were able to take the creature that had
been spotted on herrick's body cam
during the first mission finally
appeared it was huge with long white
Limbs and no facial features except for
a huge mouth it grabbed herrick's
companion and literally ate the top half
of his body in a single bite before
dropping his legs to the ground this
horrifying Beast and the many others
like it would later be designated as
scp-3989-2a Herrick pulled out his
sidearm and shot the creature several
times the creature ignored the bullets
though and charged Herrick the feed from
his body cam cut out soon after both men
were declared killed in action and in
recognition of his sacrifice Josiah
Herrick was posthumously reinstated to
his old position in the foundation job
well done agent Dr gazelli meanwhile
prepared for the next mission this time
knowing of the clear dangers present
within the bone Orchard Dr gazelli
recruited the help of MTF Zeta 9 aka the
mole rats three members referred to as
Charlie team were sent into the
anomalous Zone once again remotely
directed by Dr gazelli they were
equipped with experimental ultrasound
technology so they could scan the fruit
of the trees within 3989-a without
breaking any and incurring the wrath of
3989-2a which seemed to act as century
for the trees early on in their Journey
they found the body of agent Herrick
crucified against one of the ossified
trees his skin covered in mysterious
symbols that were likely of sarcic
origin while we don't have time to fully
explore sarcasism that will require a
video explanation all of its own all you
need to know is that it's a dangerous
religious cult that worships flesh and
disease and has close ties to similar
dangerous anomalies like scp-610 also
known as the flesh that hates people
familiar with that SCP will note eerily
strange similarities to some of the
things the mole rats were about to
encounter as Charlie team explored they
saw a huge number of 3989 2as observing
them with eyeless faces from between the
ossified trees they pressed on until
they discovered what seemed to be an
entirely new kind of tree within the
bone Orchard
scp-3989-2 were huge trees made out of
what appears to be enlarged human spines
in place of a
the smaller Twigs on the tree were made
from heart and lung tissue and the whole
thing was covered in what appeared to be
human amniotic sacs Charlie team
attempted to use their ultrasound
scanners to discover the contents of
these sacks but one of them exploded in
the process releasing an entirely new
variety of monster from the sax emerged
the larval stage of
scp-3989-2b smaller humanoid monsters
with no faces No sensory organs two
pelvises four legs and an exposed spine
suddenly Charlie team could feel a
horrifying sarcic presence around them
which one member of the team described
as being like someone grabbing her liver
and giggling in her face as the various
Monsters of the bone Orchard began to
converge on the team the voice of the
sarkic prophet of War and the hunt auruk
begins sounding in their ears he was
beckoning them to join him while Charlie
team fled from the active Zone Dr
gazelli felting increasingly drawn into
it he heard the voice of orok and he
liked what he heard little by little the
workers of area 126 were losing their
minds manipulated by the sarkic power of
the bone orchard right next to them day
after day they were no longer loyal to
the foundation they wanted to serve
their new Dark Masters the fourth and
final expedition was led by Dr gazelli
himself he took a band of loyal
followers and one non-believer on a
quest into the active Zone to find an
orchian Temple they believed was hidden
in the very heart of the bone Orchard
once they were inside gazelle and his
loyalists murdered the non-believer as a
sacrifice to their new master They
carried on until they eventually found
what they were looking for a giant Stone
Temple resembling an Aztec ziggurat
dubbed
scp-3989-4 there they also encountered a
new kind of monster dubbed scp-3989 9-3
these beasts were larger than the others
and resembled ancient warriors they had
insect-like exoskeletal armor horned
heads additional Hind and forelimbs an
integrated bladed weapons what Dr
gazelli and his companions thought would
be paradise turned out to be a kind of
hell as they were led into the temple
where temporal and spatial distortions
broke their mind and the multiple highly
aggressive instances of
scp-3989-3-2a and dash 2B broke their
bodies the whole thing had been a
horrifying trap in that moment back at
area 126 another fleshy horrifying tree
sprouted out of the ground in the middle
of the complex monsters that had once
been Dr gazelli and his followers
emerged from its amniotic sacs and all
hell broke loose throughout the complex
soon enough the base was crawling with
monsters from the bone Orchard and staff
would become brainwashed sarkic cultists
working in service of Uruk humans were
gathered up to be sacrificed to the
ever-growing number of anomalous trees
things came to a head when the anomaly
in area 126 was visited by an outside
agent from the foundation working on
behalf of the Hazardous Materials
containment liaison biological
containment specialist Dr Marshall Grant
and his team arrived at the site and
were horrified to see the sarkic
nightmare that had unfolded they quickly
engaged in a firefight with the
anomalous creatures and sarkic devotees
who'd gained control over area 126. a
number of Dr Grant's team were lost in
the process but thankfully they were
able to eventually regain control of the
base and the anomalous area after this
incident
scp-3989 was upgraded to ketterclass and
given a huge upgrade in security
including four meter high concrete walls
and a platoon-sized regimen of mobile
task force members with heavy Weaponry
the force that took over the minds of
those exposed was designed made it
scp-3989-5 a force so powerful that
those infected are given the choice to
self-terminate or be contained forever
this may seem like a somewhat happy
ending to a grim Tale But one detail
keeps Dr Grant and everyone at the
foundation who is forced to deal with
39.89 awake at night according to all
recent studies into the bone Orchard it
isn't contained at all in fact the
active zone is getting bigger disturbing
things had been happening on the fifth
floor of the Rose Heights apartment
building in Albany New York residents
had reported strange noises over the
last few days Screaming in the Night
pained muttering soft weeping scratching
and scuttling in the walls and worst of
all what seemed like an infestation of
bugs unlike anything the unfortunate
occupants of Rose Heights had ever seen
before they weren't abnormal size or
shape they looked an awful lot like the
common earwig around two and a half
centimeters long with large curved
pinchers on the back but the color
wasn't right unlike the usual dark brown
these earwigs were a silverly almost
translucent gray when people spotted
them crawling across their walls or
hiding in the carpet they seemed to
Shimmer in the light eventually the
building's landlady Donna Tompkins was
called in to do something about the
infestation she spoke to each of the
residents about their experience they
reported the strange noises the
mysterious bugs and even a funny smell
they'd sometimes catch in the hall a
smell like someone had thrown up and
every single person that Donna spoke to
couldn't help but remark that the smell
was particularly strong outside the
apartment of a certain resident Bill
Parham stranger still was the fact that
bill hadn't been seen in days Donna
knocked on his door but received no
answer she called him on his cell phone
and could hear the phone ringing inside
the apartment but it just went to
voicemail when she checked the security
footage of the lobby she saw that bill
hadn't left the building in the last few
days either Donna called the police
worried that bill might be sick or even
dead inside his apartment it was strange
given that he was only in his 30s and
didn't seem to have any health
conditions but stranger things had
happened much stranger things were about
to happen too two police officers
arrived not long after they called
through the door one more time and when
they got no response Donna gave them the
key to head inside the apartment was a
rack all the furniture was covered in
dust filthy dishes were piled high in
the sink and on the draining board the
smell of rot was thick in the air there
were empty boxes of painkillers all the
pills popped from their silvery foil
laying on the ground but worst of all
for the bugs the apartment was crawling
with them and they were on every surface
those silvery gray earwigs neither of
the officers liked bugs and it seemed
like the deeper they got into the
apartment the more bugs there were some
even seemed to be crawling towards them
pointing their Pinchers at them as
though they were defending their
territory this looked to be a textbook
case of what happens when a resident
Keels over and dies but there was just
one problem where was the body Bill
Parham had seemingly dropped off the
face of the Earth and now a colony of
mysterious bugs had started squatting in
his apartment in his absence then came
that smell again that truly awful smell
like bile and blood it was even stronger
now and it seemed like it was coming
from a nearby closet the two officers
acting on pure Instinct Drew their
weapons and approached the closet with
caution even if they weren't consciously
aware of it they knew they were going to
find something awful inside something
evil something dangerous when they threw
up in the closet door they couldn't help
but scream they'd found the nest it was
a huge round Hive like the biggest
beehive you've ever seen melded into the
lower corner of the closet the unnatural
earwigs were crawling into out of and
around it thousands of them tens of
thousands of them and the second they
registered the presence of the two
officers Intruders into their nest they
began to swarm in sheer Panic both
raised their guns and opened fire into
the closet but it didn't do them any
good their bullets just pierced and
splintered The Hive causing even more
enraged insects to spill out and begin
crawling over the two cops they fled
from the apartment screaming in pain
from the gnashing pincers of the insects
crawling all over their skin they never
did find the corpse of Bill Parham but
that because Bill Parham wasn't dead at
least not until mere moments ago when
the bullets from the cops's gun had torn
through his bones and perforated his
organs he died not long after and if he
could still speak close to the end he
would have thanked them both for the
mercy because the monstrosity that they
just encountered in the closet wasn't
just a nest of mysterious insects in
Bill parham's apartment it was Bill
himself this is the Fate worse than
death in store for anyone's supremely
unlucky enough to fall victim to
scp-439 better known by the nickname for
their unique nests the bone Hive and
while these nasty little critters may be
small they're filled with enough pure
nightmare fuel to send you running into
682's containment chamber for a little
Comfort let's go through this whole
nightmarish process and tell you exactly
what happened to poor Bill Parham first
discovered by the SCP Foundation in
mainland China
scp-439 specimens large get by on the
fact that they're not much to look at
unless you're an entomologist when you
see a strange insect you probably just
accept the fact that it's a perfectly
normal breed you've just never
encountered before nobody is hammering
down the doors of their local news
station to alert the Press about the
gray earwig they saw crawling out of a
crack in their bathroom wall but if Bill
Parham had done just that it would have
saved his life the foundation would have
immediately flagged the incident as an
scp-439 infestation and dispatched a
mobile task force to deal with it
instead when Bill saw the earwig for the
first time he was getting ready for work
and didn't have the time to stop and
deal with it he made a mental note to
buy some bug killer on the way home but
quickly forgot the insect didn't forget
him though in fact it thought he would
be a perfect candidate for the scp-439
process the foundation has tested
extensively with the one scp-439 sample
they'd been able to successfully catch
and contain in all tests they found
found that 439 specimens rejected hosts
from any species other than humans
they're an extraordinarily specific
parasite it's also only one particular
type of scp-439 specimen that you
actually need to worry about the Queens
despite their superficial similarities
scp-439 behave nothing like
non-anomalous earwigs normal earwigs are
not social creatures they're solitary
scavengers and they don't keep nests as
permanent habitats the same can
definitely not be said for scp-439 they
have complex social structures much like
that of bees ants and termites with
Queens Scouts workers and warriors if
you happen to encounter a worker or a
warrior you may get a painful pinch from
their Pinchers if you get too close but
if you end up on the wrong side of one
of the Queens then you have a much much
worse fate in store for you and it just
so happened that the scp-439 specimen
that appeared in Bill parham's bathroom
that morning was visiting royalty this
439 Queen had selected her Target and
now it was time to move to the next part
of the process initial infiltration when
Bill returned home from work he was
delighted to find that the gray earwig
was nowhere to be seen but that didn't
mean it was gone it was still there
lurking it just didn't want to be seen
after all the real fun would happen
after bill went to bed once scp-439
detects that its potential host has
fallen into a deep sleep it will crawl
onto the person's body and into their
mouth which is exactly what it did to
Bill it feels like little more than a
tickle in your throat and you will have
no idea that the tiny creature crawling
down your windpipe and into the soft
warm tissue of your lungs spells your
doom very few people wake up during this
process but even if they did There's
virtually nothing they could do when
Bill woke up he was suffering from mild
chest pains and shortness of breath a
symptom not uncommon in a number of
respiratory ailments he had no idea that
the scp-439 queen was already inside him
he got up and went about his day trying
to ignore the pain as it gradually grew
worse and worse feeling almost like
something was moving inside his chest he
spent the whole day having to stop to
let out a deep hacking cough but
coughing didn't expel or change anything
he looked and felt so terrible that his
boss let him go home early hoping that
bill would be able to sleep off whatever
illness he thought he had picked up but
over the next couple of days his
condition only worsened the pain grew so
excruciating he could barely move and he
was popping painkillers like Tic Tacs to
no effect he started running a
dangerously high fever his body trying
in vain to fight back against its lethal
Intruder he felt worse than he ever had
in his life but little did poor or Bill
no the most terrible parts of the
process were yet to come through
anomalous means an scp-439 infection is
able to induce fibro dysplasia
ossifican's progressiva or fop in its
victims which is typically a genetic
disease that presents itself before the
victim turns 10 years old the condition
is Infamous for its primary symptom
turning muscle and other soft tissue
into bone slowly but surely paralyzing
the victim and putting them into a state
of unspeakable pain this bone
transformation process is known as
ossification and Bill was about to
experience it firsthand his pain
increased as his Mobility decreased with
more of his flash becoming solid lumps
of bone underneath the skin soon enough
all he knew was pain it becomes so
agonizing that he was delirious with it
he was drunk on pain even perceiving
sunlight felt like being stabbed in the
eyes that's why like all the other other
victims of scp-439 he decided to conceal
himself in a warm dark place where no
light could get to him in Bill's case of
course that place was his closet it was
hurting so bad that all he could do was
curl up into the fetal position and weep
as his muscles turned to bone and his
body began to Compact and Shrink he
didn't even look like a human anymore he
was more like a ball covered in a bone
shell and filled with warm organs that's
when the queen started laying eggs among
his organs it wasn't long before there
was a new brood of around 30 000
specimens living inside Bill's body it
was still very much alive but there
wasn't anything he could do about his
situation his muscles had long since
turned to bone and they had eaten large
portions of his brain leaving mainly the
parts needed to keep his organs just
barely functioning after all the colony
still needs central heating scp-439
colonies have developed a perfect
parasitic relationship with the human
body they even used the stomach inside
the hive to pre-digest food into a
liquid slurry that's easier for them to
consume the only loser in this situation
is someone like Bill who is forced to
become the new home for the world's most
nightmarish freeloaders eventually when
the colony becomes too big a queen
departs to start a new one and the
process repeats itself once more it's
enough to make you want to sleep with
your mouth closed for the rest of your
life oh and we haven't even told you the
worst part yet Foundation scientists
have conducted tests on some victims of
scp-439 and found that while the
creatures do consume large parts of the
brain the parts they leave are capable
of Consciousness that's right their
victims remain aware of what's happening
to them the whole time even when they
hardly seem human at all anymore what
actually finally kills the victims of
scp-439 isn't the bodily Trump it's the
starvation that sets in when the colony
inevitably moves on did we just hear you
cough you might want to go get that
checked out a woman walks through the
lonely Hills in the dead of night her
purple sorry is torn and filthy from
Days of exposure to the elements her
bare feet have been cut up and bruised
by the rough terrain she walks but her
clothes and feet are not the most
noticeable thing about her this woman is
pregnant her belly swollen two freakish
proportions it's frankly a miracle that
she's even able to walk in this state
she stumbles and sways under the weight
of the thing growing inside her whatever
it is it's too large to be any kind of
ordinary baby but she keeps moving
muttering to herself in a language that
no human ear has heard in years her eyes
are glazed over almost hypnotized she
moves with great purpose but her vacant
facial expression makes it appear as
though she doesn't know exactly what
that purpose is she just needs to keep
moving further into the wild
until it happens whatever it is the one
thing that's certain is that it isn't
anything good a car rumbles down a
nearby dirt ground it's being driven by
Dr vinay ramachandran a medical
practitioner from the nearby city of
Surat who occasionally drives out to the
more rural areas where the locals might
not have easy access to Medical Health
he spots The Staggering woman and
immediately pumps the brakes of his car
she's clearly in need of medical
attention thank goodness he happened to
be driving by the time Dr ramacharan
grabs his medical bag from the back seat
and rushes towards the woman who
collapses in a heap before he reaches
her that's when to his utter horror Dr
ramachataran notices that the woman's
belly is continuing to swell at an
unnatural rate even for a woman who is
heavily pregnant with triplets this
would still be far too large and the
rate at which she's swelling is akin to
someone blowing up a balloon by the time
Dr ramacharan reaches her the worst has
all
the woman's belly has burst open and
crouching on her corpse is the thing
that was growing inside her an adult man
nude and covered in blood Dr
ramacharan's Terror only increases when
he notices that the man is eating her
elsewhere a riot is unfolding in the
streets a megaphone wielding instigator
barks orders for violence and Chaos as
the rioters spread setting fires
smashing windows and attacking any
unfortunate civilians caught in their
way it's one of the worst riots that the
area has ever seen even the veteran Riot
comps are frightened by the ferocity of
it the cops descend and clash with a
crowd of ever advancing rioters they're
beaten back with crowbars baseball bats
knives and metal pipes and behind them
all the instigator continues spitting
his venomous words working the crowd
into an unmatchable frenzy they'll need
heavy reinforcements if they want to get
this Riot under control that's when one
of the Wyatt cops on the front line
Sergeant Abhishek notices something
strange so many of the rioters seem to
have the exact same face the face of the
instigator Another Place Another Time
four men are digging up a grave in a
desolate old graveyard they work
tirelessly all moving in perfect
synchronicity they're only interrupted
when a group of heavily armed men
crashed the party and start firing on
them but these grave robbers are
prepared all of them draw revolvers like
a gang in an old western and begin
returning fire causing the men in
tactical gear to seek cover behind the
nearby tombstones while one of the Grave
robbers continues to fire the other
three scattered during the confusion
when his gun runs dry with that Telltale
click the men in tactical gear
immediately rise up and pin cushion him
with shot after shot of their assault
rifles he does the bullet dance like
Tony Montana and collapses to the ground
but when the gunman approached to
confirm the kill there's a horrifying
twist of fate swarms of horrible red
flies start pouring out of every bull
swarming the attackers who Retreat
swatting away these horrible little
insects but there's so many of them
there's no way to stop at least some of
them from crawling into their mouths
here's an interesting fact all of these
nightmarish incidents are connected in
the year 1969 a mysterious man was
arrested in hematnagar an area in the
Indian state of Gujarat this man had
been accused of inciting civil unrest
terrorizing and distressing the local
people he was later extradited to an
unknown location after the Indian
authorities received a request from a
mysterious organization known as yep you
guessed it the SCP Foundation who could
this man have possibly been to attract
such attention the authorities thought
if that's not to question it they were
probably just glad to be rid of the
Troublemaker once and for all except
they weren't not by a long shot a few
years later in 1975 a group of four men
were discovered in a cemetery this time
in Ahmedabad another location in Gujarat
for desecrating Graves this would be
strange and upsetting enough but what
really sent things to the next level of
weirdness was the discovery that these
four men were all the same man each one
was not only genetically identical to
one another but also to the man that had
been extradited in 1969. you'd be more
than justified in asking what the hell
is going on here maybe they were just a
group of Highly rare quintuplets five
children all born from the same mother
who just happened to have a predilection
towards crime and anti-social Behavior
or perhaps something stranger was afraid
the four who appeared in the cemetery
might have been clones of the original
Troublemaker in himnatagar as relatively
simple as those explanations would be
the truth was in fact far far weirder
than mad science or coincidentally
criminal quintuplets the four from the
cemetery had been ambushed by operatives
of the global occult Coalition another
shadowy organization fans of this
channel are likely to recognize the
coalition or GOC is a group that views
itself as the police of the Paranormal
World using extremely advanced
technology to destroy Supernatural
entities and artifacts rather than
contain them they've been known to work
both alongside and against the SCP
Foundation both groups combine interest
in four genetically identical men in an
Indian graveyard seem to suggest there
was something Supernatural about their
origin one of the men had been killed by
the GOC while the remaining three were
taken into custody by the SCP Foundation
gotta love the power of teamwork but who
were these men where have they come from
and why did they share identical genes
to the first man from six years earlier
could there have been even more of them
well in the Years following the
foundation has been able to determine
that yes there are more of these
genetically identical individuals out
there across the more rural states of
India like Gujarat rajasatan Himachal
Pradesh Ariana Punjab Jammu and Kashmir
there may be over a thousand instances
of the same person collectively they are
known as
scp-2833 while their outward appearance
can vary somewhat instances of scp-2833
all share the exact same genetic traits
as each other depending on the area they
are located in these anomalous people
can speak various languages and Regional
dialects including Hindi English
kashmiri Punjabi Urdu and even an
outdated unknown language that doesn't
correspond with any known modern dialect
or language family each scp-2833 also
possesses the ability to manipulate the
organic matter of their own body now we
don't mean that these men will stretch
themselves like Mr Fantastic or turn
into something out of John Carpenter's
The Thing but they're able to use their
bodies to create
well something
scp-2833 instances can produce a small
anomalous parasite known as
scp-2833-a these are often released
through any bodily orifice like the
mouth nose or ears or through any Cuts
or open wounds suffered by an scp-2833
in other words if you shot and killed an
scp-2833 perhaps in a cemetery under the
orders of the global codes Coalition
then these parasites would still be able
to escape through the victim's bullet
wounds the only way to stop this from
happening is to incinerate the body of a
deceased scp-2833 burning them until
there is nothing left so what exactly
are these parasites well they're tiny
invertebrates meaning they're a small
cold-blooded organism with no spine that
can live on land or in water they
closely resemble dipturians which are
any order of insects that contain what
we know as flies red in color and 20
millimeters in length
scp-2833-as are composed of a
combination of muscle tissue keratin the
protein that your hair skin and
fingernails are made from and traces of
Ash strangely enough they are also
capable of flying with their two wings
and will use these to attempt to enter
the body of a suitable host while this
can be any vertebrate creature it seems
they have a preference for humans once
inside the host's body an
scp-2833-a parasite will attach itself
to their nervous system this then allows
the scp-2833 instance that the parasite
originated from to control the body of
the host taking over their bodily and
motor functions nervous system and all
of their sensory organs from here an
scp-2833 will then either subject the
target to Vivid inescapable
hallucinations or manipulate the
functions of their body the parasites
also contain a miniature instance of
another
scp-2833 only about two millimeters long
while these mini scp-2833s are usually
chemically inactive lying dormant and
unable to move this changes if the
parasite's host is a human female in
these cases the
scp-2833-8 creature will implant the
miniature scp-2833 within the uterus of
their female host after this the new
scp-2833 will begin to rapidly grow
consuming any and all organic matter
that surrounds it once again the
scp-2833 that the parasite originated
from is still able to manipulate the
female host's body and will use this
control to make her leave her home and
travel away from any Urban environment
after a year this new instance of
scp-2833 will be born in a truly
horrific fashion every time this happens
the female host is unable to survive the
process dying as a result of being used
as an incubator for the parasites the
newly formed scp-2833 will retain all
memories of the previous instance that
released the parasite they are even able
to speak fluently from the moment they
are born but that isn't the most
horrific part what happens next is that
the newborn scp-2833 will then Devour
the body of the female host that carried
it sometimes the host can die before an
scp-2833 is born with the parasite
keeping their body embalmed until the
new instance emerges but regardless the
mother of an scp-2833 will always die
during birth the SCP Foundation has
conducted a number of interviews with
the instances of scp-2833 that they have
captured and detained the first as
cp2833-1 the man causing civil unrest in
himatagar 1969 referred to himself as we
implying that all the scp-2833 instances
share the same Consciousness acting as a
hive mind of sorts one of the men from
the cemetery
scp-2833-4 elaborated further on the
nature of these anomalous beings when
asked how many of the instances existed
we are in your cages we are distant
hordes of the ignorant we are grown like
crops and livestock we are growing in
numbers and faith and we will grow until
the Ascension of samadeh samadhir is
beyond side the buried will rise to be
consumed as the doorway to rebirth this
is our cycle waiting for somebody with
patience we shall dance the tandava and
consume the world for its rebirth
samadhi is a word meaning a crypt
usually the final resting place of a
saint or someone of religious
significance additionally the tandava is
an ancient dance that according to
Legends was performed by the Hindu god
Shiva who is believed to be the source
of all things the cycle of creation
preservation and destruction so these
anomalous beings and their parasites
appeared to be awaiting the discovery of
an ancient burial site where someone or
something was prophesied to rise consume
the world and then recreate it thinking
this Sandy might pose a threat the
foundation probed a later instance of
scp-2833 for further information on its
significance if you intend to seek some
of thee your quest is in vain for we are
the inheritor to somebody only we
scp-2833-42 protested when asked about
the samadhi by a foundation researcher
one Dr Sanjay shiel samadhi does not
threaten it is we who were threatened
exiled when the colossality we are the
remnants but we are never defeated the
instance went on we are of Glorious
lineage The Chosen stock of karsis
vasque only the strongest and most
zealous may serve his purpose to that
end we consume ourselves to persist and
await for samadhi when asked who exactly
karstvaski was
scp-2833-42 answered we are we are
karsis Vasquez that word karsus has long
been associated with the religious Cult
of sarcasism another group of interests
you are likely to be familiar with if
you're a fan of what we do here this
group worships flesh and disease and is
seen as an apocalyptic Threat by the SCP
Foundation the Sarkis religion was
founded thousands of years ago by an
ancient Elder being known as the
sorcerer king of aritam also called
Grand karcissist ion the goal of
sarcasism is to bring about a new age of
Flesh elevating Humanity to the form of
gods and potentially terraforming the
entire Earth using scp-610 the flesh
that hates so who or what was karsis
vasque what role did it have in the
religion of sarcasism and how does it
link to scp-2833 the foundation has
collected a number of documents once
belonging to a man named Sir William
Henry Sleeman Sleeman was an
administrator who worked in India on
behalf of the British East India Company
before his death in 1856 and it is in
his documents that some of the answers
can be found according to Sir William
the poor of India told him about a group
of Mystics who were both revered and
feared among the country's peasantry
this group called themselves the vatula
and seemed to hold what Sleeman
described as an unusual fetish towards
death and Decay sounds an awful lot like
the sarcasts doesn't it Sir William
heard rumors that these vatula worshiped
Shiva but were never seen at temples
choosing instead to worship the Hindu
god in seclusion additionally though
each member of the vatula when asked
identified themselves by the title of
karsis vasque not everyone feared them
however as a group of men would often
attack them these men were thuggy
organized gangs of professional robbers
and murderers that traveled India
strangling their victims to death and
robbing them blind perhaps because of
this the vatula seemed wary to interact
with any other worshipers of Shiva often
dismissing them as Pretenders to the
faith hoping to appease and gain an
audience vatula sir William's allies
Unleashed what they called the daughter
of Shadows better known as scp-029 this
divided the thuggy in the hopes that the
vatula would then accept sliman as an
ally eventually he achieved an audience
with them and was unable to determine
whether the group was genuinely devoted
to their religious beliefs or was just a
group of Mad Men what Sir William didn't
realize was that under the Vestige of
karcissist vasque this group was subtly
spreading the influence of sarcasism
over India as for scp-2833 perhaps they
are the descendants of the vatula group
their lineage continuing through the
passing of those little parasites it's
highly likely that these vatula were all
early instances of scp-2833 which would
explain why those captured by the SCP
Foundation claim that they are all
karcissist vasque a few years back in
2014 one of the foundation's mobile task
forces uncovered a body that was a
genetic match to the other instances of
s
scp-2833 however this one wasn't found
in India but in krasner Ras Kai Russia
it had strange growths on its muscle
tissue and Bones carrying multiple
scp-2833-a parasites inside its internal
organs the body had even been modified
to contain an artificial uterus which
carried an infant
scp-2833 instance it seemed that not
only have scp-2833 found a new way to
evolve carrying themselves in a modified
body but they're also beginning to
spread further than ever before you
gotta hand it to the sarcasts they're
certainly adaptable gregori gusikov and
Anatoly cornev both age 10 tiptoed
through the dark Deep Woods bordering
their quaint Russian village of
operation the year was 1990. a turbulent
time for the people of Russia seeing as
the Soviet Union was on the precipice of
collapse but for these two young boys
Global geopolitics was the last thing on
their minds they were too busy hunting
for the legendary monstrous witch known
only as Baba Yaga for those in our
audience who grew up in Eastern Europe
or those at least decently familiar with
Slavic folklore and or the John Wick
film series mention of the name Baba
Yaga likely sends a slight chill down
your spine and if it doesn't just wait
by the end of this video you'll be
afraid to go into the woods alone not
that going with others would save you as
poor little Grigori and Anatoly were
about to find out the hard way they
forged on through those witchy Woods by
our standards the boys were tough and
head strong after all the Russian
Wilderness could be a brutal place to
grow up and in the town like obericheni
the old ways of stoicism and
perseverance were prized over fear and
caution all except for one particular
area the supernatural like many small
villages all over the world at every
point in history obrachen had its fair
share of local superstitions Chief among
them was the belief that the local
forest was enchanted and that when
people wandered in among the trees many
of them would never return they would
fall into the gnarled clutches of the
carnivorous witch Baba Yaga and their
bones would lay among the roots and Dead
Leaves until they someday crumbled into
dust it was starting to get dark out
when the two boys had first set off it
had been with the intention of proving
their medal among the other local
children they didn't fear Baba yanga the
old witch in the woods was just another
fairy story meant to frighten children
and they weren't children anymore though
they would never live to be men it
wasn't long before they were beyond the
point of no return which way was out and
which way was further in it hardly
mattered anymore as carrion Birds Cod
far above the bravado that put them here
was starting to falter now but neither
dared show it they'd rather be put in
Mortal Peril than show fear in front of
one another was something moving in the
distant Shadows a thin Twisted human
figure impossible to make out save for
the faint glow of its eyes and the
Gathering dark they couldn't tell what
was real and what was their mind playing
cruel tricks on them a horse whisper
issued through the brittle trees in the
moments that followed it was an ancient
voice a voice that had echoed in the
nightmares of generations a voice that
had seen centuries it spoke in an older
Russian dialect that neither of the
young boys could understand but somehow
the essence of its message still run
clear in their hearts and Minds welcome
Instagram
to my Forest hear your lies are
forbidden you are my property
I look forward to
the tender need of your numbers
that was all they needed to hear to
start running Gregorian Anatoly turn and
fled screaming for help into the
darkness of the forest both gasped as
they ran through what seemed to be a
giant spider web they spat and sputtered
trying to swat away the silky strands as
they ran from The Voice little did they
know what they just run through was no
spiderweb they tried to press on but
their footsteps slowed the forest was
changing around them twisting shifting
sparkling what had seemed terrifying
before was suddenly oddly beautiful the
two boys just stood and watched as the
Force turned into a gorgeous Technicolor
light show unlike anything they'd ever
seen before strange figures hopped and
danced through the foliage one tall
figure approached them out of the trees
a beautiful fair-haired Maiden the two
boys were entranced by her their hearts
filled with pure Golden Light why were
they running before they couldn't even
remember they just smiled as the woman
approached them in her long flowing
dress smiling back she was like
something out of a fairy tale they
didn't react they didn't even realize
what was happening as the jaws of the
horrible ancient old Crone closed around
their skulls for the last time Gregorian
Anatoly were never seen again just
another two children gone missing in the
woods the latest entries on a long list
of tragedies to hit the village of
oberichenyi but they were also the
straws that broke the camel's back the
villagers were sick of living in fear
under the fabled witch they would have
their Revenge the men of the village
gathered up their weapons and formed a
Hunting Party guns torches knives axes
and fury they would slay the Beast that
had taken so many of their friends and
their children in the woods as soon as
their forces were assembled they charged
into the forest looking for blood with
their numerical advantage and
single-minded determination it didn't
take them long to find the monster in
the woods she was every bit as hideous
and nightmarish as they had anticipated
a gnarled snarling crown with long
clawed fingers and dirty fangs they got
her in their sights and prepared to open
fire but none of them were ready for
Baba yega's counter-offensive she moved
like a leaf and a strong wind Swift and
effortless the men who'd made the
mistake of getting too close to her with
knives and axes tasted her terrible
wrath she tore through them with claws
like iron sanker fangs into their flesh
lifted and tossed them like ragdolls how
could she be so fast and so strong the
men were terrified this was no mere
woman it was a true monster squeezed
into a barely human form by the time the
creature was finally in capacitated he'd
taken countless bullets and Strikes how
any creature could survive such an
assault was unimaginable several members
of The Hunting Party were dead by this
point others had been overtaken by a
strange form of Madness a couple of them
had been given to constant giggling fits
or were speaking long strings of
nonsense others had been rendered
entirely catatonic by the experience it
was clear that the witch had powers
beyond their understanding they needed
to return it to the village and destroy
it as quickly as possible the monster
was bound and dragged back to operationi
after seeing how it Bewitched some of
the men they avoided direct contact
whenever possible they would do
everything they could to see Justice
Done of course there would be no due
process for Baba Yaga the violence that
had erupted in the forest was more than
enough proof to justify the beast's
immediate death sentence the local
priest gave a prayer though he remarked
that he was sure this monster was the
creation and servant of the devil and
the execution commenced a local used a
blessed sword Anointed with holy water
to hack off the Baba yaga's head its
body was shot several times for good
measure and it was finally doused in
gasoline and set on fire the remains
were buried just outside the village
limits hoping that the Baba yaga's evil
wouldn't continue to haunt their Town
even in death isolated villages in the
Russian step aren't famous for their
communication with Outsiders especially
back in 1990 when the Soviet Union was
still Clinging On to control and the
internet was still in its infancy it
took a few weeks for news of a village
capturing a so-called local witch to
reach the SCP Foundation after closely
studying The Peculiar disappearance
records in the area they sent over a
Detachment of field agents to
investigate and perhaps conduct a few
interviews with the locals they had no
way of knowing there wouldn't be any
left by the time they arrived when the
field agents reached oberchini it was
already a ghost Town not a single
Survivor was found only the evidence of
fresh Carnage desiccated bodies were
found in some of the Village's houses
and others only body parts a hole in the
ground next to the Village seemed to
show evidence of some Subterranean
creature clawing its way back up to the
top whatever this creature was it
clearly crawled back up from the earth
and exacted bloody revenge against those
who had buried it blood trails from some
of the bodies leading back into the
woods made it clear where the creature
had fled to after massacring the entire
Village given the sudden increase in the
Situation's severity mobile task force
Epsilon 6 AKA The Village idiots were
brought in to apprehend The Fugitive
witch but much like the literal Village
idiots that had come before them this
MTF had no idea what they were up
against they entered the forest outside
of bracheni with Superior Tactics and
weaponry to the villagers with orders to
contain the creature at all costs they
didn't exactly know what they were
searching for in the dark amongst the
trees but when the first operatives laid
eyes on the Twisted Old Crone they
almost reflexively relaxed their guard
for some of the village idiots this
would be the last mistake they ever made
some of the operatives began to feel
funny much like Grigori Anatoly and some
members of The Hunting Party they began
to see the forest warping and shifting
around them they giggled at all the
funny colors and sighed feeling an
overwhelming sense of calmness and
Euphoria it was honestly the best they'd
felt in years perhaps they were wrong
about hunting the witch in here maybe
the real anomaly here was a Russian
Forest that made you feel awesome when
you stepped inside while the affected
agents were giggling away in their own
little La La Land Baba Yaga was bringing
the pain with the same freakish speed
strength and ferocity that had surprised
The Hunting Party weeks earlier the
witch was tearing through MTF Epsilon 6
ripping through hardened tactical armor
with her long claws and teeth she took
shot after shot enough tranquilizer to
put down an elephant but she kept
fighting in the end the training and
numerical superiority of the task force
won out they were able to secure and
contain the Baba Yaga soon redesignated
scp-352 and take it to a nearby
Foundation containment site for further
studies there they officially recorded
all the details from the creature's
incredible speed and strength to its
regenerative abilities so extensive that
it could even survive being decapitated
and burned but what about the
hallucinogenic of facts like a hungry
spider the Baba yaga's true power comes
in her ability to spin a deadly web her
body is able to produce long thin
hair-like fibers each one coated in
powerful hallucinogenic enzymes that
induce a sense of placid euphoric
Stillness in its victims when it is an
engaging multiple targets the creature
can sometimes take multiple days to
consume a single still living victim
taking them apart in them piece by piece
speaking of eating as you can probably
imagine in order to keep scp-352
uneventfully contained it's ideal to
make sure it isn't hangry in order to
keep 352 well fed they need to stock up
on its favorite food human flesh those
specifically 352 has a real Hank ring
for babies while the foundation are
currently exploring anomalous means of
keeping the Baba Yaga fed until those
means are fully ironed out they need to
keep this monster fed the old-fashioned
way only ever withdrawing food as
punishment if it attempts to breach
containment after all there's a very
good reason why parents and children
across the Slavic World fear Baba Yaga
she's always hungry and in the end she
always gets what she wants who doesn't
love their pets right whether it's a dog
a cat a goldfish or a hamster any pet
owner will tell you that their furry
friend is so much more than just an
animal that they adopted to many pets
become permanent additions to the family
while they might not look like a human
being or even have the ability to speak
the way we do a lot of owners view their
pets as people in their own right of
course a person can't be a pet at least
a human person can't right well not
unless you happen to be a part of
scp-1897 otherwise known as the human
domestication Society if you've ever
been brave enough to travel alone to the
rural parts of Southwestern States like
Arizona New Mexico Texas Oklahoma Utah
or Nevada then it's likely you would
have been an ideal victim for
scp-1897 this designation doesn't refer
to one single creature or entity but
rather a group of similar beings witness
testimonies and photographs of
scp-1897 depict them as humanoid
creatures standing approximately 5
meters in height these beings have
displayed a speed and strength far
beyond that of any human they are
capable of traveling roughly 200 meters
in only 9 seconds and lifting weights of
up to 500 kilos with a single hand these
entities are not Immortal and can be
harmed by conventional means but that
doesn't mean it's an easy task nescp
1897 instance that is killed or
incapacitated immediately vanishes
resulting in them dropping anything that
they may have been carrying at the time
and surprisingly these are not mindless
monsters and actually appear to be
capable of communication furthermore
they do not seem to speak a unique or
distinct language but instead
communicate in standard American English
with accents and vernacular appropriate
to the regions they appear in however
they will actively refuse to reply to
any human that attempts to engage them
in conversation now these creatures
don't spend every waking hour of the day
roaming around the states of Texas
Oklahoma and all the others we listed if
they did it's likely a lot more
civilians would have spotted them by now
and would probably live their lives in
fear of these gigantic five meter tall
humanoids but instances of scp-1897 will
only manifest if certain specific
criteria are met and these are as
follows to encounter
scp-1897 a person must be alone or part
of a group of no more than two if more
than one person is with them the no
manifestation will occur there is one
exception to the rule if a child under
the age of 12 is present secondly
neither the person nor anyone with them
can be carrying any kind of weapon that
means no knives no guns not even pepper
spray third and finally they must be at
least 25 meters from a major population
Center and what happens when all of
these conditions are met and one of
these creatures appear anyone witnessing
their arrival will notice the creatures
materializing appearing to emerge from
some form of unseen vehicle when they
manifest the scp-1897 entities are
almost always carrying long poles with
large Nets at the end as well as steel
cages and are often seen wearing dark
green uniforms in most cases they will
attempt to capture any nearby person in
a way that causes them the least
possible harm should an scp-1897
creature successfully apprehend a person
and place them in a cage both them and
their captive will vanish in a similar
manner to the way the creature appeared
all attempts to track
scp-1897 or one of its abductive victims
have failed there is no way to know
where they are taken but as far as what
happens to them that we do have a little
more insight to sometimes although it is
a highly rare occurrence the captured
human victims May reappear around a
month after their capture while never in
the same location as where they
disappeared from they will always be
accompanied by an
scp-1897 instance and will stay close by
the creature's side at this point the
abductee is barely human anymore they
are considered an instance of what is
known as
scp-1897-1 what signifies this sudden
and drastic transformation for one these
victims are always found to have been
forcibly castrated or sterilized
essentially no longer able to reproduce
the way humans naturally do for another
these instances of
scp-1897-1 universally display a
decreased level of cognitive and mental
function what we mean is that their
brains do not function the way they
should anymore instead these abductees
exhibit the same level of intelligence
and capability as the average canis
lupus familiaris otherwise known as the
common domestic dog should someone
attempt to rescue a person that has
become an instance of scp-1880 37-1 or
display hostility towards the scp-1897
creature that accompanies them they will
be met with outward animalistic
aggression from the victim it has been
discovered by the SCP Foundation that
these behaviors can be treated with
amnestics unfortunately though the
process of an abducted person becoming
an
scp-1897-1 instance seems to be the
result of an invasive medical procedure
known as a lobotomy this typically
involves removing or disabling certain
parts of the human brain meaning that
what has been done to these victims is
permanent and cannot be reversed so who
is doing all this why are these
creatures collecting innocent human
beings only to reduce them to little
more than animals the answers lie in
something currently referred to as
scp-1897-2 not another creature or
entity not an anomalous artifact or
location with strange properties but a
website found at the address WWE
www.hdsociety.gov according to the
information on this site it belongs to a
group calling themselves the human
domestication Society the website
features Pages such as adoption training
breeding programs volunteering and more
the fact that this is the kind of
website you might expect to be about
dogs or cats but instead focuses on the
domestication of humans is certainly
enough to turn the stomach as we said at
the start of the video surely a human
being can't be somebody's pet right
wrong at least as far as the human
domestication Society goes their website
contains everything and anything one of
these
scp-1897 creatures could ever hope to
learn about owning a human as a pet has
your Human been misbehaving need to
train them to use the toilet these Pages
have all the information you need to
help your human become the most
well-trained human on your block boast
the training page of
www.hd society id.gov the remainder of
the page contains links to various
articles such as obedience training
which claims an owner of a human can
show them whose boss without the need
for physical violence also featured are
mentions of how to toilet train or play
fetch with a human how to introduce a
human to others due to them naturally
not getting along perhaps most chilling
of all is one article titled
understanding what your human wants that
warns human beings shouldn't talk and
another dealing with Strays offers tips
for anyone wanting to learn to capture
their own pets themselves it doesn't
seem like too much of a leap to think
that the scp-1897 creatures have
followed a lot of the advice from this
particular article arguably worst of all
is an image featured on the website of a
tall menacing
scp-1897 entity brandishing a picana
electrica this device for any unfamiliar
with the term is a form of high voltage
electrical battle prod normally used for
the purposes of torture in the
photograph in question the creatures
wielding one of these while standing
sternly over a helpless captive human
male now an instance of
scp-1897-1 with tears in his eyes
further Pages found on
www.hdsociety.gov recommends solutions
to certain human behaviors for example
like one might expect to find on other
Pet Care websites some of the human
domestication society's articles pertain
to dealing with aggression grooming
house training and even toilet training
then there's the adoption page which
states we offer a large variety of
humans for adoption every single day
while we cannot guarantee a human UC
listed on our website will be available
when you reach the shelter our inventory
is updated every half hour we cannot
answer any questions about specific
humans pictured on our website over the
phone or email it is still unclear
whether or not the SCPA 1897 creatures
that have been known to appear in the
southwestern United States are sent out
to gather humans and Mass to offer for
adoption or whether these creatures are
individuals trying to obtain human pets
on their own of course the worst
conceivable answer is both the site is
horrifyingly comprehensive with links to
an actual human ownership convention
with panels on breeding and preventing
illegal human poaching and skinning it's
safe to say if that you were ever
unlucky enough to read this website it
would Haunt You for Life naturally the
SCP Foundation has made several attempts
to contact the owners of this website
they tried in vain to communicate
through the official channels about
scp-1897-1 adoption as a way of
peacefully negotiating that the human
domestication Society website be shut
down as well as its practices of
capturing lobotomizing breeding and
adopting humans however these
communication attempts were met with
silence that is until a message was
received by the found Foundation at
site-06 addressed to a member of
personnel that does not exist no data
pertaining to the physical location of
the sender could be derived from the
email but it was traced to the same IP
address as the human domestication
society's website the email read it as
follows we will not listen to your lies
any longer it was you who came after us
first you who tore holes in our world
and tried to annihilate us you who took
our olive branch of peace and fashioned
it into a spear you who nearly drove us
to Extinction and now that we have the
advantage you attempt to patronize us
with your crocodile tears we will not be
deceived again but unlike you we're not
monsters we have much anger towards your
kind but we are willing to forgive but
first you must be willing to change
slavery and genocide are immoral and not
even you deserve such a fate it is our
belief then that this alternative is a
fair compromise between guaranteeing our
safety and allowing your kind to live
this is our Mercy to you look at the
humans who have gone through our program
see how much happier they are your
correspondence tells us that you have
seen them see how much they love us why
then do you continue to be defiant
someday you will thank us please try to
understand that this is for your own
good for now there is little that the
SCP Foundation can do to prevent the
human domestication Society from
abducting human beings to sell us pets
to other
scp-1897 creatures civilian access to
thehdsociety.gov website has been
restricted so we recommend you stop
typing into the search bar of your
browser to go take a peek yes we mean
you seriously stop that as for the
entities that have appeared in the rural
areas of the southwestern States all the
foundation can do is position its agents
nearby in the hopes that they can detain
and neutralize the
scp-1897s as they appear with lethal
Force if necessary at present the only
procedure for any human pets that are
successfully recaptured is to have them
moved safely to containment until a way
of rehabilitating them is found so far
there hasn't been any luck on that front
help me with somebody please help me I'm
lost and I can't see it echoed through
the alley in a thin Reedy voice that
suggested brittleness of body and spirit
who wouldn't hear that cry and feel a
Pang of sympathy are you so heartless
that you'd ignore the desperate pleas
for help of a blind man clearly in
distress for all you know he might even
be in danger what if he walks into a
road and gets hit by a car would you
really want that on your conscience
questions like these were flying through
the head of the Good Samaritan when he
decided to go and investigate when it
seemed like everyone else was just
intend to pretend they didn't hear it
and carry on with their day as normal
the Good Samaritan was a person not
unlike yourself they were also the kind
of person we all hoped and wished we
would be in a situation such as this
kindness and generosity is a virtue
after all the problem is there are
people out there who know this and are
willing to take advantage of that
kindness and generosity but even worse
is the fact that there are things that
are definitely not people out there
willing to take advantage of human
compassion too but back to the Good
Samaritan he approached the sound of the
distressed man in the alley he looked
old and frail hunched over with the
weight of his ears he wore thick dark
glasses and his white cane was laying on
the road a few feet away from him it was
a tragic scene but thankfully the Good
Samaritan was here to help he approached
the old man calmly telling him that it
would be okay the Good Samaritan picked
up the walking cane and passed it over
to the blind old man him his face spread
into a warm smile and he said thank you
thank you thank you young man
it warms my heart to know there are
still good people like you on this Earth
the old man told the Good Samaritan that
he'd come into town to get some fresh
air and a little exercise at which point
he'd gotten lost when the Good Samaritan
asked whether it was safe for him to
come alone the old man told him that he
always used to go on walks with his wife
but ever since the accident she didn't
seem to want to be seen in public the
Good Samaritan naturally felt for the
old man who seemed as sweet as he was
feeble he offered to escort the old man
back to his house personally wanting to
make sure that he returned home safely
the old man smiled and graciously
accepted saying that his wife would
probably want to thank the kind young
man for helping him in person of course
the Good Samaritan was so wrapped up in
the warm glow of doing a good deed that
he never once stopped to question the
strangeness of this whole situation he
just walked along with the old man
listening to him tell his fanciful
stories as they left the city center and
crept further into the Sleepy outskirts
of their small Kentucky Town it was just
rambling on as old men tend to do he
told the Good Samaritan a little more
about his beloved wife she was a kind
woman who'd he'd known for as long as he
could remember his elementary school
sweetheart then his high school
girlfriend and not long after they
graduated his beautiful Blushing Bride
oh yes she'd always been the prettiest
lady until the accident curiosity was
getting the better of him the Good
Samaritan couldn't help but ask what
exactly the accident he kept alluding to
was and the old man was all too happy to
give him an answer not that this answer
was in any way Pleasant his wife had
been trapped in a terrible fire in town
that gave her severe burns all over her
body she was lucky to be alive but the
Flames took her beauty and her
confidence away from her since then
she'd become a real homebody often
refusing to leave the house and rarely
ever letting strangers see her the good
Samaritan's heart ached for this poor
old couple why were such nice people
often forced to endure so much suffering
did this old man even have anyone else
to talk to they reached his house soon
enough it was the furthest one on the
end of the street right next to the
darkness of the woods it looked old and
dilapidated but it wasn't like the old
blind man could even know that as they
were walking up the small set of stairs
to the porch the old man stumbled
slightly causing his thick dark glasses
to fall to the floor the Good Samaritan
reflexively leaned over to pick up the
glasses for the old man as he passed
them back he noticed something strange
the old man wasn't just blind he
literally didn't have any eyes just two
black empty sockets where his eyes
should be the Good Samaritan was just
thankful that the old man wasn't able to
see him staring as he put the glasses
back on the two of them entered the
house the Good Samaritan was too busy
thinking about the old man's empty eye
sockets to even notice him locking the
door behind them and by then it was
already too late for him the old man
called out into the dark expanse of the
house sweetheart I've got you alive
before the Good Samaritan could ask what
he actually meant by that the old man
shuffled off definitely navigating the
Halls through memory alone and took one
of the two seats at the dining table he
just sat there smiling waiting that's
when the Good Samaritan heard the
creaking sound coming from above
something moving up in the darkness of
the second floor and then descending the
stairs with heavy clumping footsteps
when his eyes came into focus in the
dark he saw it there the most terrifying
thing he'd ever witnessed coming down
the stairs towards him it was vaguely
human in its shape alone but in all
other respects it was a monster through
and through this gnarled Twisted
creature with bulging eyes dead flesh
and filthy exposed fangs like it stepped
straight out of a nightmare and into the
physical world where it did not belong
there looked to be a huge hole in its
lower torso too with no blood or organs
inside just an infinite blackness the
creature's lipless mouth Twisted into a
smile the creature said something in a
voice that the Good Samaritan couldn't
understand it was the black tongue
something ancient terrifying and unknown
as the creature got closer and closer
the Good Samaritan turned and made a run
for the door he tried to figure out the
lock his hands fumbling and
uncoordinated by fear he could hear the
footsteps and the heavy breathing of
that thing getting closer behind him he
was so close almost there that's when a
strange black substance seemed to encase
the world around him it separated him
from the door he was so nearly able to
breach locking him in he was trapped
inside what looked like a giant black
sphere made of some unknown material or
energy he turned to see that monster
standing right behind him just grinning
and waiting for the inevitability of
this situation to sink in the Good
Samaritan had never been more terrified
something else began to shift inside the
sphere her a structure was growing out
of the ground up and around him like a
cage within a cage he was trapped and
huddled inside a strange conical
structure as more figures entered the
sphere around him they were just like
the first this horrible horde of
desiccated knot people all with grinning
lipless mouths when they closed in on
him the Good Samaritan had the one
consolation that at least it was over
but it wasn't not yet the blind old man
waited in the kitchen for five hours as
unmentionable Horrors unfolded inside
the black sphere the Good Samaritan was
actually lucky all in all because for
some sessions for victims inside the
sphere had lasted as long as 27 hours he
screamed the entire time with a sphere
finally demanifesting just moments after
the screaming stopped remaining was only
one of the creatures but no Good
Samaritan just several neat piles of
human organs arranged by organ type I
are you down in there honey the blind
old man asked I've been getting awfully
hungry the creature replied in perfect
English
[Applause]
the creature picked up some of the
discarded organs and took them into the
kitchen where it began cooking them into
a stew for the old man he ate the stew
not long after blissfully ignorant to
its contents and went to sleep whatever
organs from the Good Samaritan weren't
used in the stew were simply thrown into
the fireplace to burn away into ashes
later that night the old man would die
peacefully of a heart attack in his
sleep at age 81. he spent the latter 10
years of his life in service of
scp-957 he'd never even had a wife and
when the monster first invaded his home
he wasn't even blind he'd simply come
home one day to find scp-957 lurking in
his home waiting for him as far as the
SCP Foundation is aware it always
targets people who live alone the man
had tried to resist but the creature was
freakishly strong in spite of its wiry
frame it grabbed him and forced his body
into the dark gaping Chasm of its chest
he was swallowed up into another world
on the other side of the void and
returned four hours later a changed man
his eyes were gone and he now firmly
believed that scp-957 was his beloved if
burnt scarred wife of many years he'd do
anything for her even heading out into
the world and feigning distress to lure
people back into her terrible clutches
that's how the Old Man became
scp-957-1 he wasn't the first and
wouldn't be the last but the old man now
dead scp-957 would Dem manifest and head
off in search of a new victim invading
their home and repeating the cycle once
more somewhere else the somewhat happy
ending is that in one of these cases the
SCP Foundation somehow got wise to the
baiting activities of scp-957 and they
were able to contain the creature giving
it the ketter object class for its
frequent attempts to either get out or
lure in new victims it's never been
actively hostile to Foundation
researchers and guards just a little
obtuse despite the fact that it's
perfectly capable of speaking fluent
English it prefers to speak in an
unknown dead language for somewhat
mysterious reasons very little is known
about the origins or true nature of
scp-957 but our brief glimpse into its
interior life does little to comfort Us
in 2008 the foundation recorded 957
having a conversation with an unseen
individual in its native tongue
Foundation linguistic experts have been
able to partially crack the code on what
was being said that day 957 asked the
Unseen figure how much longer it would
have to stay here the figure told it
that it would need to wait there for a
while and that its disguise was
extremely convincing 957 complained that
being here was boring and tiresome but
the Unseen figure urged 957 to remain
patient it said
foreign
before we start today's video we need to
ask you a question are you alone in the
room seriously are you alone you may
think the room around you is empty but
how can you really know that right think
of the technology out there being
developed by groups like DARPA the CIA
or even the SCP Foundation secret agents
and cloaking suits could be standing
around you right now watching your every
move without you even knowing you could
tell someone about this but if you did
they'd think you're crazy and nobody
believes crazy people do they sometimes
people's whole worlds just collapse one
day they're living happy successful
lives with families and friends who love
and care about them then the next day
they're truly convinced that the US
government is tapping not only their
phone calls and their emails but their
thoughts perhaps even putting dangerous
brain waves directly into their mind or
they start to believe that those loving
family members and Friends seek to do
them harm Maybe maybe they start to
believe their food is poisoned and stop
eating causing them to waste away from
malnutrition most terrifying of all
maybe they start to see things that
nobody else could see monsters that defy
rationality and shake the very Soul
terrible terrible things these are all
sadly relatively common symptoms of
someone suffering from a severe case of
schizophrenia a mental illness with a
wide range of detrimental effects to
sufferers first and foremost giving them
an incredibly complicated relationship
with reality there's sadly a lot of
misconceptions in the media about people
who suffer from illnesses like
schizophrenia painting them as unstable
individuals who present a danger to the
people around them in reality people
with a condition like these are three
times more likely to be a victim of a
violent crime and they're also more
likely to be a victim of something else
too like we said earlier sometimes
people's worlds just collapse and in
severe cases they might simply drop off
the map and nine times out of ten the
reason for that is
scp-870 the maybe they're monsters take
the experience of Katrina Wayne she was
an office temp in Tallahassee Florida
with an undiagnosed case of mild
schizophrenia for the most part she was
able to operate just fine at her job
getting her work done at a satisfactory
level while also maintaining a decent
social life after hours it came as a
shock to everyone when she began
screeching horrifically in the middle of
the office she backed herself up against
the wall picking up nearby objects and
throwing them into the aisles at some
invisible Foe and this isn't a metaphor
there really was an invisible foe moving
towards her and only she could truly see
it seeing the huge scaly body of a
mature alligator from the Florida
Everglades moving towards you would be
scary enough on its own but this wasn't
any ordinary alligator its long
reptilian head had three eyes instead of
two and it moved towards her on eight
huge articulated spider legs it was like
something straight out of a nightmare
Katrina was put on leave due to a
stress-induced mental breakdown and
prescribed a course of antipsychotic
medication by a psychiatrist she
disappeared from her home without a
trace a mere two weeks later or take the
story of Daryl Simon he was a mechanic
working in Michigan with a family
history of schizophrenia though he'd
never been officially diagnosed himself
he was working on the engine of a
vintage Corvette when something strange
happened his garage began to fill up
with smoke he considered that at first
perhaps it was some kind of engine
malfunction causing smoke to belch out
of the old Corvette's tailpipe but then
he saw something standing in the smoke a
human figure Daryl suddenly felt a
profound sense of dread seeping into his
mind he grabbed a monkey wrench and
began to slowly approach the Intruder
standing in the smoke it was only when
he was already too close that he
realized the figure wasn't just standing
in the smoke it was made of smoke the
second he he noticed this the figure's
eyes opened glowing red its Smoky face
opened into a wide toothy mouth and let
out an ear-splitting shriek Daryl
suddenly found himself running as the
creature gave Chase he threw his wrench
as it ran it breezed through the
creature's semi-intangible form Daryl
was found later that day huddled in the
corner of his garage muttering
incoherently after seeing a mental
health professional and sharing his
story he was given a schizophrenia
diagnosis he was given a mix of talk
therapy and medication and seemed to be
improving over time he would
occasionally report hallucinations of
the man made of smoke watching from the
corner of his eye but it was dismissed
as nothing more than that a
hallucination a month later he was gone
never to be seen again but he wasn't the
only one to fall victim to the anomaly
Shirley Nicholson a retiree whose
schizophrenic symptoms developed later
in life was having a quiet evening in
her home when she first encountered an
instance of scp-870 she was watching a
game show on television and when she
heard a strange noise coming from her
kitchen a rustling like someone was
messing with the food inside her fridge
of course she always had a tendency to
hear things which was why she wasn't
that nervous when she got up and walked
to the kitchen that sense of confidence
didn't last long when she entered the
kitchen she saw the fridge door open
with the back half of what looked like a
giant ant emerging from it her breath
caught in her throat that giant ant
which seemed to be eating the food
inside her fridge suddenly froze seeming
to realize that Shirley had entered the
room when it backed out of the fridge
surely couldn't help but scream instead
of antennas and mandibles the giant ant
had a grinning human face as Shirley
screamed the giant ant's human face
began to cackle with sadistic Glee its
jaw began to stretch open impossibly
wide exposing the never-ending Darkness
within Shirley turned and ran as the
creature skittered towards her at a
frightening speed adrenaline kicked in
and surely ran for her life as the
monster pursued her through the house it
was only when she ran out into the
street and was seen by others in this
bizarre Outburst that the horrifying ant
monster seemed to disappear and several
weeks after her schizophrenia diagnosis
Shirley Nicholson sadly disappeared too
before she vanished she made a panicked
9-1-1 call where she screamed down the
line that the monster had come back no
explanation has yet to be found but
there are more cases to be investigated
still Don Jones who had a documented
history with schizophrenia had his
scp-870 experience while waiting for the
bus out of town late one October evening
he was checking his phone at the bus
stop when he saw a figure shuffling
towards him in the distance he tried to
ignore it at first years of therapy had
taught him to try his best to ignore
these strange little anomalies he had
been medicated for years and while
occasionally he had minor episodes he'd
live with the condition for long enough
now that he'd learn how to cope that was
when the strange shuffling figure got
closer Don looked up just for a moment
to see the thing coming towards him out
of the dark it was about the size of a
child though a little shorter because of
how far the creature was hunched over
literally hunched The Entity had a
rather prominent Hunchback but this
wasn't nearly as noticeable as the
thing's face it had the head of a
particularly mangy looking parrot its
curved beak caked in what looked like
old blood this was Stranger than some of
the hallucinations he'd suffered in the
past it looked more tangible more real
even after years of medication and
therapy he felt nervous as the thing
approached him on some subconscious
level he knew the thing intended to harm
him in one way or another when it opened
its mouth and sunk the bladed tip of its
beak into Don's hand he knew that he
wasn't dealing with any mundane fantasy
here he screamed and ran off into the
night the monster giving Chase he later
reported the incident to the police but
his fears were written off when his
medical history came to light everyone
just assumed the man was experiencing
another episode and that the wound in
his hand was self-inflicted and of
course as you've probably gathered by
this point poor Don Jones would
disappear Without a Trace not long after
still the testimonies get freakier a
warehouse security guard Alex Landry had
his terrifying encounter while on the
job he was on his nightly Patrol when he
heard a strangely soft skittering noise
coming from inside the warehouse he
deployed his flashlight and ran inside
after radioing for assistance he was
expecting maybe an escaped animal or a
young hoodma messing around inside what
he didn't expect was a face-to-face
encounter with pure Terror as his
flashlight beam traced its way up to the
top of the warehouse he saw a monster
crawling across the ceiling it was a
giant 15-foot long centipede but instead
of having normal centipede legs it had
scores of twitching grasping human arms
he was found in a comatose state by his
partner and spent the brief rest of his
life in a psychiatric facility before
you guessed it disappearing Without a
Trace and most exhilarating we come to
The Tale of Mr Holgate which both ends a
little more hopeful for him but paints a
grim picture of what happened to
everyone else Mr Holgate had encountered
a spider-like creature with a freakish
number of legs which he soon realized
only he could see during his periods of
observation he'd seen the creature both
devour a ruler as in the measurement
device not a king as well as swallow a
human whole after an extended period of
stalking the victim leaving nothing
behind just like the scp-870 instances
had done to all of their other victims
when the monster eventually came for
Holgate he was ready it ran screeching
towards him on its too many legs and
Holgate whipped out a gun and shot it
the foundation had prioritized the
capture or destruction of scp-870 it's
believed to be not a single instance but
an entire species living out there
preying on humans and hiding in the
space between our perceptions even two
schizophrenic people looking at the same
instance will report seeing completely
different entities the monsters are all
the more dangerous due to the fact that
sufferers of severe schizophrenia often
report hallucinations of strange
monsters or entities so their pleas for
help are often ignored by neurotypical
authorities neurotypical meaning those
who don't experience any form of mental
illness personality disorder or
developmental condition people who could
never see scp-870 coming until they're
already being swallowed whole the lead
researcher on the scp-870 case follows
up the file on the monsters with an
ominous note that leaves little comfort
for even those of us who don't suffer
from schizophrenia the note reads I
personally don't believe that the
schizophrenics are really seeing as CP
870 Folly they can just see it more than
us we don't see it because our brains
aren't made to see it the schizophrenics
their brains are wired up just that tiny
bit differently and they can see it just
a tiny bit more these things have the
perfect camouflage and we simply are
unable to see through it to return to
what we said at the very beginning of
this video look around the room and
answer our question are you alone now at
least you know the answer to that
question may not be as simple as it
seems now go check out evil monster
created by SCP Foundation
scp-2419 The Laughing men and revenge of
d-class ghosts
scp-4973 Dead Men Walking for more scary
anomalous beings that'll have you
looking over your shoulder